SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA,
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. DURAZO.
EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO SEYARTO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND THE GUESTS
BEHIND THE RAILING. PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH, PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. SISTER WE GATHER
IN GOD'S PRESENCE. LOVING GOD,
ON THIS LABOR DAY WEEKEND, WE
PRAY FOR ALL WHO SHOULDER THE
TASKS OF HUMAN LABOR. WE THANK
YOU FOR THE GIFT AND OPPORTUNITY
OF WORK. MAY OUR EFFORTS RESULT
IN BLESSINGS FOR THE LIVES OF
OTHERS. WE PRAY FOR ALL THOSE
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT. MAY THEY BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR SEARCH FOR
FULFILLING WORK. WE PRAY IN
GRATITUDE FOR THE VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THOSE WHO ARE
NOW RETIRED. MAY THEY ENJOY THE
FRUITS OF THEIR LABORS IN ALL WE
DO. MAY OUR WORKING AND OUR
RESTING GIVE PRAISE TO YOU, OUR
GENEROUS GOD. AMEN PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. GOOD MORNING TO
EVERYONE. EVERYONE EXCEPT NINER
FANS. GOOD MORNING. THERE WILL
BE NO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
TODAY. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF A
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ.
WE ARE NOW UNDER MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WOULD
ANY MEMBER LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS? I
AM SEEING NO MEMBERS UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THAT
DISREGARD. SENATOR ASHBY, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. PLEASE MOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER 28 AB 2688 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER 29 AB 3054 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. AS NOTED, SENATOR GLAZER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED IF
APPROPRIATE, I'D LIKE TO MOVE
SENATE BILL 1382, OF WHICH I AM
THE AUTHOR, TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. APPROPRIATE. THE DESK IS
NOTED. SENATOR CABALLERO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE AB 2849
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO TO THE
INACTIVE FILE AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. THE DESK IS NOTED.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. ANY OTHER
MEMBER WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED.
SENATOR EGGMAN. GREAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. PLEASE REMOVE AB 2060
SORIA TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK IS NOTED. LAST CALL. I'M
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBER WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES,
LET'S DIVE INTO THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
SECOND READING FILE FOR ITEMS
ONE AND TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
8218. SECOND READING FILE WOULD
BE DEEMED READ. WE'RE NOW
JUMPING INTO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
COLLEAGUES. WE AS YESTERDAY THE
COUPLE OF DAYS ARE GOING TO BE
PERHAPS JUMPING AROUND WHEN
MEMBERS ARE OFF THE FLOOR. WE'RE
GOING TO BE SOMETIMES SKIPPING
THOSE THAT HAVE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SO WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH IT TWICE, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING IF A FLOOR TEAM IS
TELLING YOU YOU'RE NEXT AND
PERHAPS YOU'RE NOT NEXT TO BE
KIND, BECAUSE WE'RE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO ADAPT AND BE FLEXIBLE
TODAY, STARTING WITH THE THREE
UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS IS
FILE ITEM NINE, TEN AND 11.
SENATOR ASHBY IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1454 BY SENATOR ASHBY IN
RELATION TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS. SENATOR ASHBY. MADAM
PRESIDENT, SB 1454 IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE AUTHORIZING
THE BUREAU TO ISSUE
ADMINISTRATIVE CITATIONS TO
REPOSSESSORS IN VIOLATION OF THE
COLLATERAL RECOVERY ACT AND
REQUIRING PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS
TO ENTER INTO WRITTEN AGREEMENTS
WITH THEIR CLIENTS AND PROVIDE A
COPY TO THEIR CLIENTS AS RETAIN
THOSE RECORDS FOR TWO YEARS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
UPON. WE'RE LOOKING TO ESTABLISH
40 ON THIS ROLL CALL SO WE COULD
DO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL MOVING
FORWARD. NEED ALL MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR ANY DISCUSSION ON ITEM
NINE? I'M SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE PADILLA.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE
PADILLA. AYE AYE. 39. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS ARE BY SENATOR LIMON. SHE
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ FILE ITEM TEN. SENATE BILL
1266 BY SENATOR LIMON. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRODUCT SAFETY.
SENATOR LIMON. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES. SB 1266 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. IT PROHIBITS THE
USE OF BISPHENOLS IN ANY
JUVENILE FEEDING, SUCKING, OR
TEETHING PRODUCTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE. MILO AYE.
OCHOA. BORG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
COLLEAGUES. WE LASTED FOR ONE
FINAL ITEM. WE'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING THINGS ON CALL. SENATOR
LEHMAN, YOU HAVE OUR ITEM 11.
SENATOR LEHMAN MOVES ACROSS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
11. SENATE BILL 299 BY SENATOR
LEHMAN AND ACT RELATING TO
VOTING. SENATOR LEHMAN, THANK
YOU. SB 299 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
WILL GRANT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AUTHORITY TO CREATE AND
ADOPT REGULATIONS TO GENERATE A
LIST OF PEOPLE PRE-APPROVED FOR
REGISTRATION FILTERS.
NON-CITIZENS FROM THE MOTOR
VOTER REGISTRATION PROCESS UPON
THE DMV TRANSACTION, AND TAILORS
THE MOTOR VOTER PROCESS TO
WHETHER THE PERSON IS
UNREGISTERED OR ALREADY
REGISTERED TO VOTE IN
CALIFORNIA, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY MIX UP, NO
DISCUSSION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. NO. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY.
NO. DODD. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO. JONES NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. SENATOR
LIMON MOVES THE CALL. THE NEXT
THREE UPPER FIVE. ITEM 12, 13
AND 14. SEN. NEWMAN. ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR FIVE? ITEM 12.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 707 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. AN
ACT TO SOLID WASTE. SENATOR
NEWMAN, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS SB 707 IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND IT WILL
ESTABLISH A FIRST IN THE NATION.
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA FOR
CLOTHING AND HOUSEHOLD TEXTILE
RECYCLING. MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN TO THE
ASSEMBLY AS A RESULT OF AN
INTENSIVE, DELIBERATE AND
CONSULTATIVE TWO YEAR LONG
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT PROCESS,
AS WELL AS ACCEPTING TECHNICAL
FEEDBACK FROM CAL RECYCLE
THROUGHOUT. RECENT AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSED THE RESPONSIBILITIES
OF ONLINE MARKETPLACES WHILE
MAKING VARIOUS TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES. ON THE BASIS
OF THESE AMENDMENTS, THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND THE AMERICAN APPAREL AND
FOOTWEAR ASSOCIATION HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION. SB 707
NOW HAS MORE THAN 150
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT,
INCLUDING WELL-KNOWN BRANDS LIKE
H&M AND IKEA, AND NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. SPECIAL CREDIT GOES
TO JESSICA MATLOCK ON MY STAFF
FOR HER EXCELLENT WORK ON THIS
BILL. OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
LONG YEARS, I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR. COLLEAGUES,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. NO. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SEGATO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
SENATOR. NO. SEN. NEWMAN MOVES
TO CALL. SENATOR ALLEN. YOU HAVE
FIVE. ITEM 13. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1143 BY
SENATOR ALLEN. AN ACT TO PAINT
PRODUCTS. SENATOR ALLEN, MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO 1143.
REDUCE THIS BILL FROM COVERING A
WIDE RANGE OF HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE TO AN EXPANSION
OF THE STATE'S PAINT STEWARDSHIP
PROGRAM TO ALL PAINT AND PAINT
RELATED PRODUCTS. WE'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING IN THE FALL ON THE
BROADER BILL, BUT THIS WAS AN
AREA THAT EVERYBODY COULD AGREE
ON. THE STATE ALREADY HAS A
SUCCESSFUL PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM FOR
PAINT. IT'S CALLED PAINT CARE
AND THAT MANAGES LEFTOVER
ARCHITECTURAL PAINT THROUGH
EDUCATION AND CONVENIENT
LOCATIONS FOR COLLECTION. AND
THEN REUSE AND RECYCLE. SO THIS
BILL, SO AEROSOLS WERE ADDED TO
THE PROGRAM LAST YEAR. CERTAIN
PAINT PRODUCTS ARE STILL NOT
INCLUDED. THIS BILL ADDS THOSE
PRODUCTS TO THE PAINT CARE
PROGRAM. THERE IS NOW NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE. I
SEE NO MIX UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. AYE. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD.
AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NØ. NILO NØ. OCHOA.
BOGH PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK AYE. SENATOR
ALLEN MOVES THE CALL. SENATOR
BECKER HAS FILED 14 WITH
SUPPORT. SUPPORT SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 537 BY
SENATOR BECKER. AN ACT RELATING
TO MEMORIALS. SENATOR BECKER,
THANK YOU, COLLEAGUE. I RISE TO
PRIDEFULLY PRESENT THIS BILL 537
WITH MY COLLEAGUE, OUR MAJORITY
LEADER, JUST FOR A MOMENT,
BECAUSE THE WHOLE POINT IS TO
RAISE AWARENESS. THE POINT OF
THIS BILL WAS TO RECOGNIZE A
MASSIVE INJUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND IN THIS STATE WHERE
WE FORCIBLY DEPORTED BY
PRESIDENTIAL ORDER, OVER 1
MILLION MEXICANS AND MEXICAN
AMERICANS IN THE 30S TO CREATE,
MAKE WAY FOR JOBS FOR, QUOTE
UNQUOTE, REAL AMERICANS. THERE
WAS NO DUE PROCESS THERE WERE
MASSIVE RAIDS, VIOLENCE AND WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO IS CREATE A
SPOT FOR A MEMORIAL, AND WE WILL
CREATE A NONPROFIT THAT WILL
RAISE MONEY TO CREATE A REALLY
PROPER MEMORIAL TO THIS EFFORT.
AND AT THIS TIME, IN THIS
COUNTRY WHERE THERE'S RHETORIC
ABOUT MASS DEPORTATIONS, AND I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE, KIND OF
WASH OVER THAT WITH OTHER
RHETORIC COMING FROM CERTAIN
POLITICAL FIGURES, IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS DID HAPPEN AND
CERTAINLY COULD HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE IT DOES
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN. COLLEAGUES, A
REMINDER ON CONCURRENCE ONLY
SPEAK TO THE AMENDMENTS OF THE
BILL. MAJORITY LEADER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED, I TOO, JUST WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BECKER FOR
THIS BILL AND FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT, LIFT UP THE
VOICES OF MANY MEXICANS AND
MEXICAN AMERICANS WHO, LIKE
MYSELF, HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
WERE DEPORTED DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER.
YOU MAY CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY AYE. DODD
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. SENATOR
BECKER MOVES THE CALL. WE HAVE
ONE FILE, ONE FINAL ITEM ON THIS
LIST FOR UNFINISHED BUSINESS
FILED ON 15. SENATOR UMBERG.
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 918 BY SENATOR UMBERG. AN
ACT RELATING TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY SIMPLY ADD 72
HOURS. A 72 HOUR WINDOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND EXTEND
THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE BY SIX
MONTHS. I VOTE THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY DODD. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. MILO.
AYE OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO ACIERTO. SKINNER. SEYARTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE SENATOR UMBERG MOVES
TO CALL. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK PAUSE.
WE ARE NOW MOVING INTO ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. THE FIRST THREE
UP ARE FIVE. ITEM 27, 31 AND 35.
SENATOR BECKER HAS FILED FROM
27. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2453 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, VILLA PADUA AND ACT
RELATING TO WEIGHTS AND
MEASURES. SENATOR BECKER. THANK
YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2453
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
VILLA PADUA. THIS WILL
STREAMLINE THE MAINTENANCE AND
REPAIR PROCESS FOR CHARGING
STATIONS. HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE TODAY. I AM SEEING
NO MIX UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO
GILL. AYE ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ I DALY.
AYE. DODD DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMON. AYE MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN WHEN? AYE MILO. AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERNE. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR BECKER MOVES THE CALL.
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS FILED ITEM
31. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1930 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES AN ACT TO TEACHING
CREDENTIALS. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ELOISE REYES TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1930, WHICH
ADDRESSES CRITICAL STAFFING
SHORTAGES IN EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS BY REMOVING
RESTRICTIONS ON ASSOCIATE
TEACHER PERMIT RENEWALS, AB 1930
WILL HELP KEEP TALENTED, CARING
AND EXPERIENCED ASSOCIATE
TEACHERS IN OUR CLASSROOMS BY
PROVIDING A PATHWAY TO PERMIT
RENEWALS BEYOND THE CURRENT
ALLOWANCE OF TEN YEARS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. I SEE NO MIKES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL A ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS I BECKER.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD. DURAZZO EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE HURTADO I. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMON MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. EBCLC. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERNE
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE WILK AYE. SEN NEWMAN MOVES
THE CALL. WE'RE ADAPTING. WE'RE
MOVING. WE'RE GOING TO SKIP
THROUGH ITEM 35. THE NEXT THREE
UP ARE FIVE. ITEM 3744. QUICK
PAUSE.
ALL RIGHT. THE CORRECT THREE
NEXT FILES ON DECK ARE FILE ITEM
37, 42 AND 44. SENATOR HURTADO
IS NOT. SENATOR HURTADO PASSES
ON FILE PHÐ. FILE ITEM 42 IS UP
SEN. WIENER PHÐ. ITEM 42. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM 42.
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1961 BY SENATE
MEMBER WICKS AND ACCORDING TO
FOOD ACCESS SEN WIENER. I THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT AB
1961 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TASK FORCE THAT,
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN STATE
HISTORY, WILL DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC MASTER PLAN TO END
HUNGER IN CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES NEARLY HALF OF THE
NATION'S FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
HOWEVER, MORE THAN 1 IN 5
RESIDENTS ABOUT 8.8 MILLION
PEOPLE, CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH FOOD SECURITY. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER, I SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. D¯ÚI. HUESO
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE. WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. AYES 39. NO. ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING BACK TO
ITEM 37. SENATOR HURTADO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2104 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SORIA. AN ACT
RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATOR HURTADO,
SUPPORT. SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. GOOD
MORNING. AB 2104 HAS SUPPORT,
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WONDERFUL
SENATOR HURTADO, ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM? SENATOR THERE IS
NO DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. BLAKE SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
NEWMAN. WHEN? AYE NILO. AYE.
OCHOA BOG. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. AYE.
CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK NO. LET'S CALL THOSE
ABSENT MEMBERS, PLEASE. ALAN
ASHBY. BECKER AYE. MCGUIRE. MIN
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO ROTH. STERN.
AYES 31. NO'S ONE.
AYE. AYE PORTANTINO. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME.
ON ITEM 37. AYES, 31, NOES ONE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
FOUR ON DECK IS FIVE.
WE'RE BEING FLEXIBLE TODAY,
COLLEAGUES. WE'RE BEING
FLEXIBLE. THE NEXT THREE ON DECK
ARE. ITEM 44, 47, AND 48.
SENATOR LIMON IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 44,
ASSEMBLY BILL 2490 BY SENATE
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE. SENATOR
LIMON, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2490 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
PETRIE-NORRIS, WHICH WILL EXPAND
AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE CARE AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS OUR STATE. AB
2490 ESTABLISHES THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE.
ACCESS TO EXPAND AND IMPROVE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IN
EMERGENCY ROOMS ACROSS OUR
STATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. I SEE NO MICS UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL NØ
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY NØ. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE LEHMAN. AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NÓ NILO. NO. OCHOA.
BORG. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SEYARTO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. NO BRADFORD.
AYE AYES. 30. NOES NINE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR LAIRD
HAS FILED ITEM 47. SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1828 BY SENATE
MEMBER WALDRON. AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR LAIRD. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND THANK YOU FOR THE
VERY UNSUBTLE JOG, THIS BILL
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET DATES ON
THE NATIVE CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE
REHABILITATION, VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION FUND AND THE RARE
AND ENDANGERED SPECIES
PRESERVATION VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION PROGRAM UNTIL
JANUARY 1ST, 2032. THERE'S
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYE'S 39 NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR LIMON
HAS FILED ITEM 48. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2837
BY SENATE MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN AN
ACT TO CIVIL ACTIONS. SENATOR
LIMON, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2837 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
KHN. AB 2837 PROTECTS LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO A DEBT COLLECTION JUDGMENT BY
BY PRESERVING THEIR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS, ENSURING DUE PROCESS
AND ACCURACY IN WAGE
GARNISHMENTS AND BANK LEVIES,
AND PROVIDING THAT AMOUNTS
WRONGFULLY SEIZED OR RETURNED TO
THE CONSUMER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I SEE NO MIX UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
DODD. DALY NO. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. LAIRD. JONES
NO. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MAGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA BERG. NO. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO NO. SKINNER.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
AYE MAGUIRE. AYES 30. NOES NINE.
THE MEASURE PASSES. COLLEAGUES
FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF ABOUT TEN
BILLS THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ASKING YOU
STAND ON THE FLOOR SO WE CAN DO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOR ALL TEN.
FIRST THREE UP FILE ITEM 53, 54
AND 57. SENATOR SALATO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1874 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANCHEZ AND AQUILINA TO
CRIMES. SENATOR SEYARTO. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT AB 1874
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANCHEZ. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
JUDGES MORE DISCRETION IN
ISSUING PENALTIES FOR CONVICTED
CRIMINALS WHO REPEATEDLY RECORD
MINORS IN INTIMATE SETTINGS WITH
SEXUAL CONTENT. AB 1874 WILL
PROVIDE OUR JUDGES MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING
PUNISHMENTS FOR HEINOUS CRIMES.
CASES LIKE THIS. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. NO
DISCUSSION ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NO ZERO. MR.
PASSES. SENATOR NIELLO, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 54. SENATOR NIELLO,
YOU HAVE FIVE. ITEM 54. HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 2337 BY SENATOR
MEMBER DIXON AND RELATING TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. TODAY I
RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIANNE DIXON TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2337 AB 2337 WILL
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES IN PROCEEDINGS BEFORE
THE WORKERS COMPENSATION APPEALS
BOARD ON A PERMANENT BASIS, ONE
OF THE FEW THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED THAT WERE GOOD DURING
THE HORRIBLE PANDEMIC WAS THAT
AUTHORIZING, ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES, AUTHORIZING THESE
THINGS WORKED PRETTY WELL. AND
SO THIS IS A PERMANENT
AUTHORIZATION OF THAT METHOD.
THE BILL HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY, RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE, ANY
DISCUSSION, ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. AYES 39. NO. ZERO. MR.
PASSES. SENATOR WILK, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 57. THESE ARE ALL
SUPPORT. SUPPORT. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1858
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. AN ACT
TO SCHOOL SAFETY. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
I'M GOING TO APOLOGIZE TO
EVERYBODY. I SHOULD HAVE PARED
THIS DOWN, BUT I DIDN'T HAVE
TIME. SO I'M GOING TO HAVE TIME.
SENATOR KAY, AB 1858 PROVIDES
STANDARDS AND GUIDANCE FOR HOW T
K THROUGH 12 SCHOOLS CAN CONDUCT
SCHOOL SHOOTING DRILLS. AND FOR
THAT REASON, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39 NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THE CURVE BALL HERE FOR ITEM OR
JUMPING BACK TO FILE ITEM 35.
SENATOR GLAZER IS. PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 544 BY SENATE MEMBER
BRYANT. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS. SENATOR GLAZER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT, THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM
TO IMPROVE VOTER PARTICIPATION
IN JAILS FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO CURRENTLY HAVE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE. CALIFORNIA ALLOWS
FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
COUNTY JAILS TO VOTE. HOWEVER,
MANY COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL ELIGIBLE VOTERS CAN
EXERCISE THEIR CIVIC DUTY AND
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE GRANTS
TO THREE COUNTIES TO IMPROVE
IN-PERSON VOTING ACCESS FOR
PEOPLE IN JAIL. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. ANY DISCUSSION? I AM
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL Ó. AYE JUST IN
TIME. SENATOR ALVARADO HERE.
YOUR YOUR. THANK YOU. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR WHAT PURPOSE? ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL MAKE IT. I'LL MAKE
IT WONDERFUL HERE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I AM HERE TO
OFFER HELPFUL AMENDMENTS BY
SIMPLY ADDING THE LANGUAGE FROM
MY SENATE BILL 226, WHICH. YES.
FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO YOU RISE
BEFORE YOU READ? I RISE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF OFFERING FRIENDLY
AMENDMENTS. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE AT
THE DESK. AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL SET ONE. SENATOR
ALVARADO GILL, PLEASE PRESENT
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WAKING ME UP THIS
MORNING, MADAM PRESIDENT, I DO
OFFER THESE HELPFUL AMENDMENTS
BY SIMPLY ADDING THE LANGUAGE
FROM MY SENATE BILL 226, WHICH
HAS PREVIOUSLY PASSED THIS
HOUSE, 36 ZERO. THIS HAPPENED
WHILE I WAS A DEMOCRAT. SO THE
QUESTION IS, WILL THIS VOTE BE
DIFFERENT NOW THAT I SIT WITH
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS, THESE
AMENDMENTS ADD ILLEGAL FENTANYL
TO THE EXISTING LIST OF
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
ILLEGAL TO POSSESS, WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY POSSESSING A
LOADED, OPERABLE FIREARM.
CURRENT LAW OUTLAWS THE
POSSESSION OF CERTAIN DRUGS,
SUCH AS HEROIN, COCAINE, AND
METHAMPHETAMINE AS A
MISDEMEANOR. IT ALSO MAKES THE
SIMPLE POSSESSION OF THESE
DRUGS, WHILE ALSO POSSESSING A
FIREARM A FELONY. THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE PRO GUN SAFETY, A
POSITION THAT THE SUPERMAJORITY
HAS EMBEDDED IN ITS PLATFORM
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. AS WE ARE
ALL AWARE, A GRAVE THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY EXISTS TODAY IN
THE FORM OF THIS DRUG CALLED
FENTANYL. IT IS AN UNDISPUTED
FACT THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
THE RISE OF FENTANYL USE. WHILE
IT HAS CAUSED THE NUMBER OF
ILLICIT DRUG RELATED OVERDOSES,
POISONINGS AND DEATHS TO
SKYROCKET AMONG EVERY SECTOR OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT MANY DRUGS CURRENTLY
ON THE LIST ARE OFTEN LACED WITH
FENTANYL, THIS DEADLY DRUG HAS
NOT BEEN EXPLICITLY INCLUDED IN
THE LIST OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES THAT ARE ILLEGAL TO
CARRY WITH A FIREARM, WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE CLARITY TO THE
COURTS BOTH IN PROSECUTION BUT
ALSO IN DEFENSE. FOR THOSE OF US
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT PUTTING
MORE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE IN
JAIL, THIS FRIENDLY AMENDMENT
ALSO PROTECTS THE DEFENSE. WHY
WOULD WE NOT WANT TO DO THAT?
TREATING FENTANYL WITH A GUN
DIFFERENTLY THAN HEROIN WITH A
GUN DOES NOT SERVE JUSTICE FOR
ANYONE, NOR DOES IT MAKE
PRACTICAL SENSE, GIVEN THE
POTENCY AND THE DANGER OF
FENTANYL COMPARED TO THE OTHER
DRUGS ON THIS LIST. THESE
AMENDMENTS CRAFT A SIMPLE,
NONPARTIZAN SOLUTION TO A
SERIOUS PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA. I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
REPRESENTING SAN YSIDRO AND THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY FOR HOSTING A
BORDER VISIT OVER THE SUMMER
BREAK. DURING THAT SUMMER BREAK,
BORDER VISIT, I, ALONG WITH SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES, WERE ABLE TO
SEE FENTANYL. FENTANYL BEING
DELIVERED CROSSING THE BORDER.
WE HAVE WONDERFUL TECHNOLOGY AT
THE BORDER, BUT WHAT WE DO HAVE
IS WE HAVE AN EXCESS OF
TRAFFICKERS CROSSING THE BORDER
AND NO MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY WE
PUT TOWARDS IT, WE HAVE A REAL
ISSUE WITH FENTANYL. SO THESE
AMENDMENTS WOULD HELP US TO
FIGHT THIS CRISIS THAT WE ARE
SEEING OVER THE BORDER. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADER
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS WHO JOINED
US ON THIS BORDER VISIT TO SEE
THE TRUE PROBLEM WITH FENTANYL.
AND ALTHOUGH SHE STRIPPED ME OF
MY LATINO ISM BY TAKING ME OFF
THE LATINO CAUCUS BECAUSE I'M A
NOW REPUBLICAN, PLEASE STICK TO
THE MERIT OF YOUR AMENDMENTS. I
STILL OFFER THESE FRIENDLY
AMENDMENTS FOR FENTANYL. SO I
REMIND YOU THAT THIS IS A
NONPARTISAN ISSUE. AND ALTHOUGH
I'M A LATINA THAT IS NO LONGER
WELCOME IN THE LATINO CAUCUS, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
AMENDMENT, AND I SUPPORT OF
THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU,
MAJORITY LEADER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I MOVE THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS BE LAID ON THE TABLE
AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MAJORITY LEADER IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE. SENATOR ALVARADO
HILL. IS LOOKING FOR A NO VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON MOTION TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS
ON THE TABLE. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DAWLEY. NO. DODD AYE. AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MAGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
WAHAB. WIENER. AYE WILK. NØ.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. WAHAB AYE. AYES 30.
NOES NINE. THE AMENDMENTS HAVE
BEEN LAID ON THE TABLE. WE ARE
NOW RETURNING TO THE BILL IN
CHIEF. ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
BILL IN CHIEF? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALI. NÓ DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. Þ. GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO NILO. NO. OCHOA.
NO PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO SEYARTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK NO.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE HOLD ON
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ROLL ONE MORE TIME. WE'RE JUST
FIXING ONE VOTE RIGHT NOW.
HURTADO I DON'T KNOW, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
COLLEAGUES. IT'S GETTING REALLY
LOUD IN HERE. IT'S HARD TO HEAR.
IF YOU HAVE ANY CONVERSATIONS,
PLEASE TAKE THEM OFF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN. AYE MCGUIRE. PORTANTINO
AYE. RUBIO AYE. AYES 29. NO'S
TEN. MEASURE PASSES. WE HAVE
FILED ITEM 30. UP NEXT, SENATOR
STERN IS GOING TO BE PRESENTING
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ FOR ITEM
30. THE ASSEMBLY BILL 2513 BY
SENATOR VETERAN. AN ACT TO
GASTOS SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
THIS BILL, SO I'M GOING TO TAKE
ANOTHER SHOT AT IT BY JUST
MAKING AN ADMISSION. SO WHEN I
MAKE EGGS IN THE MORNING FOR AVA
AND LENNY, I IT'S ANNOYING TO
HAVE THE VENT ON. AND IT'S LOUD
IN THE KITCHEN, AND I WORRY I'M
GOING TO WAKE EVERYBODY UP. AND
SO, I USUALLY DON'T TURN IT ON,
TURNS OUT YOUR 24% MORE LIKELY
TO GIVE YOUR KIDS ASTHMA IF YOU
DON'T TURN ON THE VENT. JUST
TURN ON THE VENT. THAT'S ALL
THIS BILL SAYS IS A WARNING
LABEL FOR DADS LIKE ME WHO MAYBE
DON'T KNOW BETTER, TO PUT THAT
WARNING LABEL ON YOUR YOUR GAS
STOVE. SO YOU'RE LESS LIKELY TO
GIVE YOUR KIDS ASTHMA. IT
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING ELSE, SO FOR,
CONFOUNDED DADS LIKE ME AND
EVERYONE ELSE OUT THERE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? I'M
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO GILL. NO
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY. ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO. CORTEZ I DALY. NÓ
DODD NO DURAZO I EGGMAN NO.
GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LEHMAN I MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR I
MIN NEWMAN. NO. NGUYEN NO. NILO.
NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
I STERN I UMBERG. WAHAB I WIENER.
I WILK. NO AYES. AYES 21. NOES
11. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE. ITEM 61, 62,
68. ALL ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. PLEASE STAY ON THE
FLOOR. SENATOR ARCHULETA, YOU
HAVE FIVE. ITEM 61. IT IS
SUPPORT. SUPPORT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1821
BY SENATE MEMBER RAMOS AND ACT
RELATING TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION.
SENATOR ARCHULETA THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY IN.
IN REFERENCE TO AB 1821 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS FOR FAR
TOO LONG. CALIFORNIA FIRST
PEOPLE AND THEIR HISTORY HAS
BEEN IGNORED AND MISREPRESENTED
BY THE STATE CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTIONS OF THE SPANISH
COLONIZATION AND THE GOLD RUSH
PERIOD FAILED TO INCLUDE THE
LOSS OF LIFE, LIBERTY, AND THE
LAND OF NATIVE AMERICANS. AB
1821 WOULD BUILD UPON PREVIOUS
EFFORTS BY THE AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS, TOWARDS AN
ACCURATE HISTORY AND TO MAKE IT
A REQUIREMENT THAT SCHOOLS TEACH
ON THE TREATMENT AND
PERSPECTIVES OF NATIVE AMERICANS
DURING THE SPANISH COLONIZATION
AND THE GOLD RUSH ERAS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK TO ESTABLISH OUR 40 FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SECRETARY,
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS.
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALY I DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD I LIMON
I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I'M IN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK I
AYES 40 NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR TROY BOG YOU
HAVE ITEM 62 SUPPORT. SUPPORT.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1938 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. AN ACT TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SENATOR TURBO THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, AND
MEMBERS, AS COAUTHOR I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1938, WHICH DIRECTS
LEAS TO CONSIDER THE UNIQUE
COMMUNICATION NEEDS OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE DEAF OR HARD OF HEARING.
THE BILL SPECIFIES THAT
INCLUSIVE PRACTICES INVOLVE
PLACEMENT IN ENVIRONMENTS THAT
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
COMMUNICATION TOOLS AND SERVICES
STUDENTS NEED TO THRIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM?
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 38. NØ
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR LEMON, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 68. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3223 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO FOSTER YOUTH. SENATOR LEMON.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
3223 ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. THE BILL
CLARIFIES YOUTH WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO A JUVENILE COURT PETITION AND
WHO HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS AT
RISK OF PLACEMENT, ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
COORDINATING PROGRAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON FILE ITEM 68,
SECTION TWO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. AYES 38.
NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. THE
NEXT THREE ON DECK ARE. ITEM 69,
70, AND 71. SENATOR BLAKESBURG
IS PREPARED. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2842 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN AND ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS. SENATOR
SPEER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB 2842, WHICH IS A
CRUCIAL STEP TOWARD PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM THE DANGERS OF
GHOST GUNS. WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
RETRIEVES FIREARMS THROUGH
EITHER GUN BUYBACK PROGRAMS OR
OTHER MEANS, COMMUNITIES ARE
AFFORDED A SENSE OF SECURITY.
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT
SURRENDERED WEAPONS ARE
PERMANENTLY REMOVED FROM
CIRCULATION. HOWEVER, A 2023
INVESTIGATION DONE BY THE NEW
YORK TIMES FOUND THAT THIS WAS
NOT THE CASE. THE REASON IS THAT
THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS TASKED
WITH THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
FIREARM WERE ONLY REQUIRED BY
CONTRACT TO DESTROY A SMALL
PIECE OF THE WEAPON. OTHER
PIECES OF THE WEAPON WOULD THEN
BE RESOLD ONLINE AND COULD
BECOME GHOST GUNS. AB 2842 WILL
CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE AND PROHIBIT
CONTRACTS FROM CONTAINING A
PROVISION ALLOWING THE RESALE OF
FIREARM PARTS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY CITIES GUN SAFETY
ORGANIZATIONS, AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM? ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 38. NO
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
ARCHULETA IS UP AND READY.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. A SENATE
BILL 366 BY SENATE MEMBER PETRI
NORRIS AND ACT RELATING TO HUMAN
SERVICES. SENATOR. SUPPORT.
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT AB
366 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRI
NORRIS, WHICH WILL HELP OUR HELP
UNDERSTAND OR I'M SORRY WILL
HELP THE UNDERSTAFFED COUNTY'S
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT TO
GROW THEIR WORKFORCE. COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES DEPARTMENT DO
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK
IN OUR COMMUNITIES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS, CHILDREN
AND ELDERLY AND THE POOR,
DISABLED AND DISADVANTAGED
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND FOR THESE REASONS, I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND AN AYE VOTE.
ANY MIX UP FOR DISCUSSION. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 38. NO
AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR GROVE IS
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT ITEM. ITEM
71. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3156 BY SENATE
MEMBER JOE PATTERSON AND ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL CENTER
GROVE. SUPPORT. SUPPORT THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 3156. THAT'S
JOINTLY AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOE PATTERSON AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NGUYEN AB 1331
56 WILL ENSURE THAT PROVIDERS
AND INSURANCE CAN ACCEPT ALL
MEDI-CAL FEE FOR SERVICE CLIENTS
ONCE THEY MOVE INTO A MANAGED
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, UNDER THE
LATTERMAN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ACT, INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING SERVICES FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDI-CAL, BUT UNDER THE NEW
CAL AIM INITIATIVE, IT WAS
PASSED IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL, FORCING REGIONAL CENTERS,
YOUTH AND ADULTS TO ENROLL IN
MEDI-CAL AND PRIMARY INSURANCE,
WHICH MEANS THEY WERE LOSING
THEIR DOCTORS. THIS FIXES THAT
JOE PATTERSON AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NGUYEN WOULD BE
GRATEFULLY APPRECIATIVE OF A AYE
VOTE. I THINK THAT I APPRECIATE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL AS WELL. ANY
OBJECTION, ANY DEBATE, ANY
DEBATE ON THE ITEM? NO
OBJECTION. AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, OUR
FINAL ITEM. 77, 79 AND 84.
SENATOR HURTADO IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 77.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2661 BY SENATOR.
MEMBER. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY. SENATOR HURTADO,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB 2661 WILL HELP
ACHIEVE CALIFORNIA'S RENEWABLE
GOALS BY LEVERAGING THE EXISTING
CAPABILITIES OF WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT TO DELIVER NEW SOLAR
GENERATION AND TRANSMISSION
LINES AS GROUNDWATER BASINS
ADAPT, ADOPT SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PLANS,
MANY REGIONS OF THE STATE ARE
EXPECTED TO EXPERIENCE AS MUCH
AS A 20% DECLINE IN AVAILABLE
WATER SUPPLY BY 2030, DUE TO
THIS MASSIVE CHANGE, IT'S
ESTIMATED BETWEEN 500,000 AND
900,000 ACRES OF FARMLAND MAY
NEED TO BE FOLLOWED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY ALONE, THIS
FALLOWED FARMLAND CAN BE THE KEY
TO EXPANDING OUR SOLAR
GENERATION. WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT WAS IN THE BEST
POSITION TO IDENTIFY SUITABLE
FALLOWED FARMLAND IN THEIR
SERVICE TERRITORY FOR CONVERSION
TO SOLAR GENERATION CAN HELP
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO, WHILE
MAKING UP FOR LOST WATER SUPPLY
REVENUES NEEDED TO CONTINUE
SERVING THE REMAINING WATER
CUSTOMERS. UNFORTUNATELY, THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH TRANSMISSION
CURRENTLY PLANNED FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO CAPITALIZE ON
THIS OPPORTUNITY. AB 2661 WILL
GIVE WESTLANDS WATER DISTRICT
THE AUTHORITY TO BUILD, OWN AND
OPERATE TRANSMISSION LINES AND
OTHER FACILITIES TO CONNECT THIS
JUNIOR GENERATION NEW GENERATION
TO THE GRID. THIS WILL HELP US
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROVIDING
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THE NEED FOR SKILLED AND
WELL-PAYING JOBS IS CRITICAL.
THE PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
UNDERTAKEN THROUGH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
HELP THESE WORKERS UPSKILL AND
ENTER INTO TRADES, WHICH WILL
UPLIFT THESE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SO OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE INVESTMENTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY DISCUSSION ON THE SENATOR
CABALLERO? YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
STAND UP IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I'VE HAD SOME CONCERNS BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY, THE VALLEY HAS
BEEN THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS BEEN
VIEWED AS THE ABSOLUTE BEST
PLACE TO PUT SOLAR ENERGY. AND
THE PROBLEM WITH WITH OVERDOING
IT IS THAT, WE'RE TAKING AWAY
JOBS IN AGRICULTURE AND WE'RE
NOT REPLACING THEM WITH, WITH
HIGH WAGE JOBS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
ENERGY GENERATION, WHICH IS
DIFFERENT FROM THE WATER ISSUES
THAT THEY NORMALLY DEAL WITH.
NOT ONLY THAT, SO THOSE ARE THE
HIGH ROAD JOBS THAT ARE GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IF WE HAVE TO REPLACE
FARMING BECAUSE WE NO LONGER
HAVE WATER, WE HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT REPLACES IT THAT
CREATES ECONOMIC WEALTH FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT LIVE THERE. BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT, THERE IS A
COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY BENEFITS
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING IN THE DISTRICT. AND SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD SINCERELY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB 2661
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REMARKS, SENATOR AND SENATOR
EGGMAN, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS, AND A FEW YEARS
AGO I DID A BILL THAT ALLOW USE
FOR SOLAR LAND TO STILL THEN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR WILLIAMSON
BENEFITS. THAT I THINK IS A GOOD
IDEA. SO WHEN TIMES CHANGE,
PERHAPS PEOPLE CAN GO BACK AND
WE CONTINUE TO KEEP THAT LAND
MORE PRISTINE. I ALSO ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR, SEEING NO OTHER
MICS UP, SENATOR HURTADO, YOU
MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR WILK,
YOU HAVE FIRED ON ITEM 79.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1978 BY SENATE MEMBER
SANCHEZ. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. SUPPORT. SUPPORT.
SENATOR, PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYWOMAN SANCHEZ AND
ANNIE, I PRESENT AB 1978, WHICH
WILL GIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ANOTHER TOOL TO CRACK
DOWN ON DANGEROUS SIDESHOWS. THE
BILL WILL ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SEIZE A VEHICLE THAT BLOCKS A
ROAD FOR THE PURPOSE OF
FACILITATING STREET RACES OR
SIDESHOWS WITHOUT NEEDING TO
TAKE THE OWNER OF THE VEHICLE
INTO CUSTODY. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. DO WE
HAVE ANY MIX UP? ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? AYES 30. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WE HAVE AN
OBJECTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. ITEM 79. ALLEN A ALVARADO
GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. NO. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. LAIRD. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. AYE. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
GROVE AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. JONES LAIRD.
MCGUIRE SKINNER. I DON'T KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
JONES. AYE LAIRD MCGUIRE. AYE
AYE. AYES 37. NOES TWO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR EGGMAN, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 84.
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM
84, PLEASE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2935
BY SENATE MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. AN
ACT RELATING TO FOSTER CARE.
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. AB 2935
PROVIDES A PROCESS THAT FOSTER
KIDS AREN'T TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
BY GETTING CREDIT CARDS AND
GETTING BAD CREDIT REPORTS. I
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. ANY OBJECTION, ANY
DISCUSSION, ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. THE NEXT THREE UP ON
DECK FIVE. ITEM 85 EIGHT.
THE NEXT THREE UP ON DECK ARE
FIVE. ITEM 85, 86, AND 87.
SENATOR WIENER IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 85.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2115 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. AN ACT RELATING TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
WIENER, I THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2115 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY, WHICH
WILL TRANSFORM CALIFORNIA FROM A
STATE WITH THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
METHADONE LAWS INTO A STATE THAT
LEADS IN ACCESSIBILITY FOR
METHADONE TREATMENT. METHADONE
HAS PROVEN TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE
WITH OPIOID ADDICTION. IT WORKS
BY EASING THE DEBILITATING
SYMPTOMS OF OPIOID WITHDRAWAL.
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE QUIT DRUGS
LIKE HEROIN AND FENTANYL, IT
ALSO REDUCES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
DYING FROM AN OPIOID OVERDOSE BY
MORE THAN 50%. IN APRIL 2024,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
RECOGNIZING THAT REDUCING
TREATMENT BARRIERS SAVES LIVES,
RELAXED MANY OF THE METHADONE
TREATMENT RESTRICTIONS. HOWEVER,
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HAVE
OUTDATED POLICIES THAT ARE MORE
RESTRICTIVE THAN FEDERAL
REGULATIONS, WHICH LEADS TO
AMBIGUITY FOR PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS AND ULTIMATELY RESULTS
IN FEWER PATIENTS HAVING ACCESS
TO METHADONE. AB 2115 WILL SAVE
LIVES BY ALIGNING CALIFORNIA'S
OUTDATED, OUTDATED METHADONE
LAWS, WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S RULING ON
METHADONE TREATMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY MEMBER
WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM?
THIS HAS AN URGENCY CLAUSE,
REQUIRES 27 VOTES. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DAILY DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
EBCLC. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DALLI
AYE. DODD AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE. WHEN
SEYARTO. ON THE URGENCY IS 38.
NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 86. TO SUPPORT SUPPORT ITEM
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3035 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AN ACT TO HOUSING.
SENATOR CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND SENATORS. AB 3035
IS A DISTRICT BILL. IT EXPANDS
AN EXISTING STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR AG EMPLOYEE HOUSING
IN SANTA CLARA AND SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. RECENT AMENDMENTS ALLOW
FARMWORKER HOUSING TAX CREDITS
TO BE RETURNED TO THE OVERALL
ALLOCATION FOR FARMWORKER
HOUSING BEFORE FINAL FUNDING
ROUNDS, RATHER THAN AFTER FINAL
FUNDING ROUNDS. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS
ITEM. ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40
NOES ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR BLAKE, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 87. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3068 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. AN ACT RELATING TO
HOUSING. SENATOR SPEER. THANK
YOU, PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 3068 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY
AB 3068. THE OFFICE TO HOUSING
CONVERSION ACT WILL ACCELERATE
ADAPTIVE REUSE PROJECTS OF
OFFICE BUILDINGS. THIS BILL IS A
RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMPTY DOWNTOWN
BUSINESS DISTRICTS AND THE NEED
TO CONVERT UNDERUTILIZED OFFICE
BUILDINGS WITHIN PRIME LOCATIONS
INTO NEW HOUSING. AS OUR WORK
CULTURE SHIFTED TOWARD REMOTE
AND HYBRID WORK POLICIES, WITH
FEWER EMPLOYEES WORKING FULL
TIME IN THE OFFICE, COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS IN DOWNTOWNS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE EXPERIENCING THE
EFFECTS OF HIGH VACANCY RATES
AND LOW FOOT TRAFFIC, AND NEED
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT TO TURN INTO
HOUSING. AB 3068 CREATES A
PATHWAY FOR, BY RIGHT APPROVAL
OF OFFICE CONVERSION PROJECTS,
ENSURING MORE PREDICTABILITY AND
FEWER BARRIERS TO AN ALREADY
DIFFICULT BUILDING PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, SENATOR WIENER, YOU ARE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. A LOT GOING ON
IN HERE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I WILL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY. I DO
WANT TO NOTE, HOWEVER, THAT THE
LABOR LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE
BILL, THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED
AROUND THIS AND SOME COMPROMISES
THAT WERE MADE. AND I UNDERSTAND
THE DIFFICULTIES. I PERSONALLY
UNDERSTAND THE DIFFICULTIES OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. THIS IS A
VERY UNIQUE BILL ABOUT OFFICE TO
HOUSING CONVERSION. IT APPLIES
IN LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES, THIS
THE LABOR LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
DOES NOT SET A PRECEDENT IN ANY
WAY. THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, BY
MYSELF ON THESE ISSUES. THE
LABOR LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL IS
UNIQUE TO THIS BILL AND TO THE
OFFICE TO HOUSING CONVERSION
CONTEXT. WITH THAT, I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. I SEE NO
FURTHER MEMBERS LOOKING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR BLAKE
SPEER, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GILL NÓ.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLY NØ. DODD
DURAZO. EGGMAN. DURAZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES NO. NO. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. NILO
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. NO BRADFORD. AYE
DODD. AYE GLAZER. NO LIMON.
PORTANTINO. OKAY. AYES 27. NOES
11. THE MEASURE PASSES. THE NEXT
THREE ON DECK ARE. ITEM 88, 89
AND 67. SENATOR PADILLA, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 88. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1878
BY SENATE MEMBER GARCIA. AN ACT
TO HOUSING. SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. 1878 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA,
TRIBAL NATIONS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
FACE SERIOUS STRUCTURAL AND
EQUITABLE OBSTACLES TO ACCESSING
AND COMPETING FOR STATE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THIS BILL WILL REMOVE
KEY BARRIERS AND REQUIRE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND OUTREACH BE
PROVIDED TO TRIBES. THIS HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, HAS
ZERO NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY MEMBER
WISHING TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM.
ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
LYMAN, YOU HAVE FILED ITEM 89.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2496 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. AN ACT TO FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCIES AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
LEMON, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND COLLEAGUES. AB
2496 HELPS PROTECT FOSTER
FAMILIES THAT PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE CARE OF OVER 9000 OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. FOLKS EARLIER AB 20
EARLIER THIS YEAR, THE REINSURER
OF NYACK, GUY CARPENTER AND
COMPANY LLC, SAID IT COULD NO
LONGER REINSURE NYACK IF IT
CONTINUED TO INSURE PHAS DUE TO
THE INCREASED LIABILITY. AB 2496
IS A TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO KEEP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE FOSTER KIDS
IN THEIR CURRENT HOMES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE,
AND ANY MEMBER WISHING TO BE
HEARD. THIS HAS AN URGENCY
CLAUSE AND REQUIRES A 27 VOTE,
BUT IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 40. NÓ. ON THE
URGENCY. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR BECKER.
YOU HAVE PHÐ. ITEM 67.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1777 BY SENATE MEMBER TÍNH.
AN ACT RELATING TO AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES. SENATOR BECKER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1777 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. THIS BILL
IS AIMED AT ADDRESSING THE
SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS
EXPERIENCED IN SAN FRANCISCO
AROUND AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND
ALSO ACROSS THE STATE TO AID
FIRST RESPONDERS AND GET UNSAFE,
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES OFF THE
ROADS. THE BILL PROVIDES FIRST
RESPONDERS WITH TOOLS THAT
CURRENTLY DO NOT EXIST TO MANAGE
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS AND
COMMUNICATIONS, AND FORMALIZES A
CITATION PROCESS TO GET THOSE
UNSAFE VEHICLES AND COMPANIES
WHO RUN THOSE UNSAFE VEHICLES
OFF THE ROAD. THIS BILL DOES
FORMALIZE A PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
CURRENTLY, THESE ARE ONLY SELF
REPORTED VIOLATIONS, AND THE
PROBLEM WITH SELF-REPORTING IS
BY IN AND OF ITSELF, IT IS A
SELF REPORT. SO WHAT HAPPENED
WITH CRUZ? THE DMV DID DO ITS
JOB AND TAKE CRUZ OFF THE ROAD,
BUT THAT WAS ONLY BECAUSE IT WAS
A VERY PUBLIC SITUATION AND THEY
CHOSE TO ACT. THIS WILL
FORMALIZE THAT PROCESS. SO
AGAIN, WE CAN GET THESE
COMPANIES AND BAD ACTORS AND BAD
VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD. AND BY
THE WAY, THIS BILL DOES DOES NOT
DO ANYTHING. EITHER WAY ON
CRIMINAL LAWSUITS, THAT IS STILL
A CASE IN POINT. I WAS JUST
GIVEN A DATA POINT THAT THE CRUZ
SETTLED A LAWSUIT WHEN IT
DRAGGED A WOMAN ABOUT 20FT. THE
SETTLEMENT WAS OVER $8 MILLION.
WE DO KNOW THAT. BUT AGAIN, THEY
DIDN'T REPORT TO DMV. LET'S SEE
THIS BILL. THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS CHANGE ONE PIECE OF
THE BILL, WHICH IS AGAIN
VIOLATING THE RULES OF THE ROAD.
THE LANGUAGE SHIFTED FROM A
REGULAR CITATION TO A NEW
CITATION PROCESS THAT, THE
AUTHOR SAYS WAS REQUESTED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL, WHO REQUESTED
THIS PROCESS. LET'S SEE.
HOWEVER, TECHNOLOGY ISN'T MAKING
MISTAKES BECAUSE OF BAD
DECISIONS OR HONEST MISTAKES.
IT'S PROGRAMED IN CERTAIN WAYS.
SO HOW WOULD A FINE CORRECT THAT
ISSUE, WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
GOING TO THE DMV IS ULTIMATELY A
POWERFUL PROCESS BECAUSE THESE
ARE MULTI-MILLION DOLLAR
COMPANIES. AND REALLY THE KEY IS
TO GET THEM OFF THE ROAD. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ENTITLED TO DO. WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT THE BILL DOES
PROVIDE THIS MECHANISM TO
COMMUNICATE WITH OFFICERS. THE
IT CREATES A PROCESS AROUND TWO
WAY COMMUNICATION SO THAT
THERE'S, THE OFFICERS DON'T HAVE
TO ENTER THE VEHICLE. THEY
COMMUNICATE WITH THE COMPANIES
AND THEY CAN TAKE ACTION AND GET
THEM OUT OF THESE EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS, WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. AYE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1777, AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
NAVIGATING THIS VERY COMPLICATED
AND AT TIMES DIFFICULT BILL
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE. SAN
FRANCISCO IS ONE OF THE FIRST
CITIES IN THE WORLD TO TEST AND
OPERATE FULLY AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES ON OUR ROADS, AND THEY
ARE THERE RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE A
PROUD HISTORY IN SAN FRANCISCO
OF AV INNOVATION, AVS HAVE THE
PROMISE, AND I CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT I SHOULD SAY AVS
HAVE A LOT OF PROMISE, AND I
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT THEY
ARE A VALUE ADD WITH RESPECT TO
SAFETY. HOWEVER, AS THE
TECHNOLOGY MATURES, THERE ARE
ABSOLUTELY GROWING PAINS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. WE'VE EXPERIENCED AVS
BLOCKING ROADS, DRIVING IN THE
CRIME SCENES, DRIVING ONTO
FIREFIGHTER HOSES DURING
EMERGENCIES, DRIVING IN
RESTRICTED AREAS, CAUSING
TRAFFIC JAMS AND BREAKING
TRAFFIC LAWS. UNLIKE THE REST OF
US RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE NO
EXPLICIT CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE
INSTANCES, AND THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW US TO SET BASIC SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE FEWER OF THESE DISRUPTIONS
AND THAT THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THE AV COMPANIES IF THEY
BREAK, IF THE VEHICLES BREAK
TRAFFIC LAWS. I KNOW THAT THIS
IS A NEW FRONTIER IN TERMS OF
HOW YOU TICKET OR SITE
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. THE AUTHOR
NAVIGATED IT THE BEST HE COULD,
WORKING WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND DMV TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PASS A LAW THAT MEETS
LEGAL STANDARDS AND THAT IS
IMPLEMENTABLE, I BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL BE AN IMPROVEMENT AND
I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR
CORTEZ, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS, I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB 1777 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING. THAT'S NO
DISRESPECT TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BUT THIS HAS TO DO WITH
THE PROVISIONS ON ENFORCING THE
VEHICLE CODE. WHEN THE BILL
FIRST CAME THROUGH THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE, I HAD
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS, AS DID
TRANSPORTATION STAFF. BUT WORKED
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ADDRESS THEM. BUT REGRETTABLY,
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON FRIDAY,
AUGUST 23RD, LESS THAN SEVEN
DAYS AGO, SIGNIFICANTLY DEPART
FROM DISCUSSIONS AND POLICY
COMMITTEE IN BOTH HOUSES AND
REFRAME THE ENTIRE PREMISE OF
THE BILL. NEW AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN, THE ONES I JUST
REFERRED TO, ARE NOT TECHNICAL
IN NATURE. I THINK WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SILICON VALLEY, THE PRESENTER,
THEY MAY SOUND LIKE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS, BUT THEY'RE NOT. AND
IN ANY ORDINARY COURSE OF
BUSINESS, TO AVOID THE KIND OF
CHAOS WE ALL STRIVE TO AVOID AS
CHAIRS AND AS VICE CHAIRS OF OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES, THOSE
AMENDMENTS, SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS SHOULD HAVE COME BACK
TO COMMITTEE. REMEMBER THIS IS
AN AB. THIS IS AN ASSEMBLY BILL
THAT STARTED LAST JANUARY AND
TOOK ITS TIME MAKING ITS WAY
THROUGH A VERY SIGNIFICANT
VETTING PROCESS TO GET TO SENATE
TRANSPORTATION, WHERE WE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR TO
MAKE ACTUAL TECHNICAL AND POLICY
BASED AMENDMENTS, IN ADDITION TO
JUST THAT BREACH OF PROCESS. AND
IT IS A BREACH OF PROCESS THAT I
THINK ANY CHAIR, ANY VICE CHAIR
IN HERE WOULD OBJECT TO. AND I'M
Dð DOING THE SAME. I'M TAKING A
STAND FOR SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN A PART OF NOT JUST THE
TRADITION, BUT THE MOVEMENT OF
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR DECADES AND
DECADES. AND DECADES, SOMETIMES
PARAPHRASED AS WHEN YOU TELL
FOLKS WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO BE,
BE THERE. AND IF YOU CAN'T BE
THERE, MAKE SURE YOU RETURN AND
LET THEM KNOW NONE OF THAT
HAPPENED WITH REGARD TO THIS
BILL, THE BILL PROVIDES NOW
INSTEAD OF A FINE THAT THE
MANUFACTURER WOULD PAY, WOULD
PAY A NONCOMPLIANCE NOTICE THAT,
QUOTE, SHALL NOT CREATE A
PRESUMPTION THAT THE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLE IS UNSAFE. THAT'S GOING
TO, FIRST OF ALL, WITHOUT FINES,
AS WE ALL KNOW, THERE'S NO COST
RECOVERY FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO EVEN GET INVOLVED
WITH THIS CONCEPT OF
NONCOMPLIANCE ORDERS. AND
SECONDLY, IF YOU GO SO FAR AS TO
SAY WHEN THEY DO WRITE A
NONCOMPLIANCE ORDER, IT'S NOT
GOING TO LEAD TO ANY LIABILITY
BY VIRTUE OF THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL. YOU'RE NOT ONLY
GOING TO GET UNDERREPORTING, BUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO GET AN
INABILITY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN HARMED TO BRING THOSE CASES
THROUGH THE CIVIL LIABILITY
SYSTEM, THE TORT SYSTEM, AND BE
MADE WHOLE, WHICH, AGAIN, AS WE
ALL KNOW, A, A LENGTHY AND
HISTORICAL PART OF OUR JUDICIAL
PROCESS, JUST AS AN EXAMPLE OF
THE UNFAIRNESS OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAVE NOW IN TERMS OF
ENFORCEMENT, WHERE A HUMAN
DRIVER CAN BE CITED OR EVEN
CHARGED FOR TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS,
AND IT HAPPENS BY THE MINUTE.
IT'S HAPPENING NOW AS WE SPEAK,
AV COMPANIES ARE ONLY NOTICED
THROUGH THE DMV. UNDER THIS
BILL. I AND SEVEN OTHER
OPPOSITION, MEMBERS OF THE
OPPOSITION STRONGLY DISAGREE
WITH THAT. IF A HUMAN DRIVER
DRIVES DOWN THE WRONG SIDE OF
THE ROAD, THEY CAN BE CHARGED
WITH A MISDEMEANOR OR A FELONY
UNDER VEHICLE CODE 21 651. IT IT
SET. I DON'T THINK THIS IS JUST
ME. AGAIN, SOME OF YOU RECEIVED
AN OPPOSITION LETTER. THERE ARE
SEVEN ENTITIES CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS,
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA, SMART ATU, CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA,
TEAMSTERS, THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF LABOR, AND
INNOCENT. CAL CITIES HAS NOW
ISSUED A LETTER JUST THIS WEEK
OF OPPOSITION. NONE OF THEM WERE
IN OPPOSITION WHEN THIS BILL
CAME THROUGH TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. SO AGAIN, I'M JUST
TRYING TO REMIND THAT THIS IS A
PERSONAL OPINION OF MINE. BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TAKEN
A BILL WHERE WE EVERYBODY WORKED
TO NEUTRALIZE OPPOSITION AND
BROUGHT MASSIVE OPPOSITION BACK,
WHICH IS ACTUALLY MORE EXTENSIVE
THAN WHEN THE BILL FIRST CAME
THROUGH COMMITTEE IN THE FIRST
PLACE, AGAIN, I APPRECIATE THE
TIME, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND I
WOULD STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE.
SENATOR GLAZER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, TO QUOTE THE I KNOW
ONE SENATOR, MANY SENATORS, I
DIDN'T INTEND TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL, BUT, A COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST, I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE PROCESS ISSUE THAT THE
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE HAS
BROUGHT UP. THAT'S NOT THE POINT
OF MY REMARKS TODAY. IT WOULD BE
JUST TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE TUSSLE
THAT WE HAVE AS WE ON MANY
BILLS, THAT THIS ONE RELATES TO,
WHERE WE'RE DEALING WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGY, THAT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO SUPPRESS. WE'RE TRYING
TO ENCOURAGE BECAUSE IT'S SO
MUCH PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
INNOVATION AND ENTERPRISE THAT
WE'RE PROUD OF. AT THE SAME
TIME, TRY TO MAINTAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY, WHICH WE ALSO IS A DEEP,
IMPORTANT VALUE THAT WE HAVE.
AND THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO WORK
IN THAT SPACE. IS IT PERFECT?
DOES IT DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
ALL WANT? NO, IT DOESN'T, BUT I
DO SEE IT AS INCREMENTAL
PROGRESS FORWARD. AND THAT'S WHY
I'M RISING IS TO ENCOURAGE A YES
VOTE ON IT. IT IT DOES ENGAGE
WITH THE DMV, WHICH IS A
LICENSING RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS
SPACE. SO THERE'S A DIRECT
REPORTING RELATIONSHIP BACK
THAT'S IMPORTANT, AND I THINK IT
ENGAGES OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
NEED TO ENGAGE IN A WAY THAT'S A
PROGRESS POINT, MAY NOT DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT, BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO BALANCE THESE
ENTERPRISES THAT ARE OUR OUR
COMMUNITY ENJOYS AND LIKES WITH
OUR DETERMINATION TO KEEP THINGS
AS SAFE AS THEY CAN BE. I THINK
THAT THE BILL STRIKES THE
BALANCE DOESN'T GO AS FAR AS
SOME WOULD LIKE, BUT I THINK
THAT'S WHY IT'S DESERVING OF
SUPPORT TODAY. ANY OTHER MEMBER
WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM?
SENATOR BECKER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU. AGAIN, SIMILARLY, I
CAN'T SPEAK TO ALL THE PROCESS
CONCERNS. I WILL SAY PERSONALLY,
I'VE SUPPORTED, VARIOUS BILLS TO
REGULATE AVS, AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY WHAT THIS ONE IS
ATTEMPTING TO DO. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DID SAY THAT THE
PREVIOUS VERSION OF THE BILL WAS
NOT OPERATIONALLY VIABLE, AND
DID OPPOSE THE VEHICLE CODE
PENALTIES BECAUSE THOSE ARE
CREATED CHANGE INCENTIVES OF
HUMANS, NOT OF MULTI-MILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES. SO IN PREVIOUS
VERSIONS, COMPANIES COULD PAY A
FINE AND GO THROUGH THE LENGTHY
COURT PROCESS. THIS DOES PUSH IT
BACK TO THE DMV, AND I KNOW NOT
EVERYONE HAS ABSOLUTE FAITH IN
THE DMV, BUT IT DOES PUSH IT
BACK TO THE DMV, WHICH DOES HAVE
CONTROL AND PERMITTING AND IN
THE CASE OF CRUZ, DID DID ACT TO
REMOVE THAT, JUST TO CLARIFY,
ALSO A LITTLE BIT, JUST ON THE
PROCESS, IT DOES REQUIRE A
DESIGNATED PHONE LINE FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS. IT CREATES A PROCESS
AND TIMELINES FOR WHAT MUST
HAPPEN WHEN A FIRST RESPONDER
CALLS, REQUIRES A TWO WAY
COMMUNICATION METHOD. IT CREATES
IN AN OPT IN GEOFENCING PROCESS.
GEOFENCING IS A PROCESS THAT
WILL REQUIRE AVS TO AVOID
ACCESSING CERTAIN EMERGENCY
AREAS. ONCE NOTIFIED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, AND THEN FOR
VEHICLES WITH A MANUAL OVERRIDE
IN THE VEHICLE. POLICE AND FIRE
MUST HAVE ACCESS AND TRAINING,
ON ITS USE. I DO BELIEVE THOSE
ARE CERTAINLY IMPORTANT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. IF
THERE'S OTHER PIECES I THINK WE
COULD REVISIT LATER AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR, FOR
YOUR CLOTHES. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO
GILL ARCHULETA. NO, NO. ASHBY. I
ATKINS. BECKER I BLAKE. SPEER I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO NO. CORTEZ
NO. DALY I DODD I DURAZZO. NO.
EGGMAN GLASER. I GONZALEZ. NO
GROVE. HURTADO JONES. NO LAIRD.
LEHMAN MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR NO.
MEN NEWMAN. I NGUYEN. NILO. NO
OCHOA. PADILLA I PORTANTINO.
ROTH RUBIO. CIERTO SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG
WAHAB I WIENER I WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GILL. ATKINS I
BRADFORD. I EGGMAN GROVE I
HURTADO. LAIRD LIMON. MEN WHEN
OCHOA I PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
CIERTO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN.
UMBERG I WILK. SEN. BECKER MOVES
THE CALL. THE NEXT THREE UP ARE
FILE ITEM 90, 91 AND 92. SENATOR
ASHBY HAS FILED ITEM 90.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2381 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILDCARE. SENATOR ASHBY, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB 2381 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIA
BONTA, WHICH ALLOWS OUR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE
BEING FUNDED BASED ON ENROLLMENT
RATHER THAN ATTENDANCE. THIS
WILL PROVIDE PROGRAMS WITH A
STABLE FUNDING SOURCE, ALLOWING
THEM TO FOCUS ON SUSTAINABILITY
AND THE QUALITY OF THEIR
PROGRAMS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ASHBY. ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE
HEARD ON THIS ITEM? ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? THERE IS AN
URGENCY CLAUSE. REQUIRES 27
VOTES. NO URGENCY. NO URGENCY
CLAUSE ON THIS MEASURE. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZE THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL I AM, I AM
SEEING NONE. AYES 39. NO, ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. AYES 39.
GREAT. SENATOR BECKER, YOU HAVE
FOR ITEM 91. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL 551 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. AN ACT
RELATING TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT. WHEN THE CPC
FIRST ADOPTED THEIR TRANSMISSION
GUIDELINES, THEY MADE THE
DECISION TO INCORPORATE THEM
INTO THEIR RULES AND PROCEDURES.
THIS WOULD EXPLICITLY EXEMPT
THOSE GUIDELINES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT TO
ALLOW THE CPC TO UPDATE THEM
WITHOUT DELAY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR BECKER.
I SEE NO MIX UP. ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? I SEE NO OBJECTION. AYES
39. NO ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR PORTANTINO HAS IT. WE'RE
PASSING ON FILE 101.
WE ARE HOLDING. THE NEXT. THE
NEXT THREE UP. WE'RE JUST GOING
TO DO ONE AT A TIME FOR RIGHT
NOW. THE NEXT ONE IS FIVE. ITEM
101. SENATOR UMBERG. WE GOT A B
518. NO, THAT'S NOT 518. WE GOT
A HOT MIC. HOT MIC. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM 101,
ASSEMBLY BILL 518 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. AN ACT RELATING TO
CALFRESH. SENATOR RON BURKE,
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. AB 518 REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
DEVELOP A METHODOLOGY TO
DETERMINE THE STATE'S CALFRESH
PARTICIPATION RATE AND
IDENTIFYING CHARACTERISTICS OF
RESIDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE BUT
NOT RECEIVING BENEFITS. I AM
INFORMED BY THE AUTHOR THAT
THERE IS CLEANUP LEGISLATION
THAT WILL BE INTRODUCED WITH AN
URGENCY CLAUSE IN JANUARY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES, AND WITH THAT, I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ELLENBERG. ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE
HEARD? I SEE NO MIKES UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MAGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. AYE NEELO. AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE SEYARTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL.
DALLEY AYE. MCGUIRE. AYES 38.
AYES 38. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR ARCHULETA, YOU
HAVE FILED ITEM 102 UP. THIS IS
A SUPPORT SUPPORT FILE ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 535 BY SENATE MEMBER CHABOT
IN AQUITAINE TO VETERANS AND
DECLARE THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS YEAR, THIS BILL,
AB 535, IS A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MANDATE REQUIRING CHANGES TO
EXCLUDE VETERANS DISABILITY
BENEFITS FROM INCOME
CALCULATIONS AND DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR VETERANS. AND
THIS IS TO SUPPORT THE VETERANS.
AND I URGE AND I VOTE, ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON ITEM
102. THIS HAS AN URGENCY.
URGENCY CLAUSE REQUIRES 27
VOTES. ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A QUICK
PAUSE HERE. MEMBERS.
ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOR ITEM
102? I SEE NONE AYES 39. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU HAVE FILE
ITEM 103. SENATOR CORTEZ IS
PREPARED FOR ITEM 103.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1034 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON. AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR CORTEZ. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATORS AB 1034
WOULD EXTEND THE EXEMPTION
SUNSET DATE FOR LAWSUITS
ORIGINATED UNDER PAGA. PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT FOR
CONTRACTORS IN THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES THAT ARE
PARTY TO A VALID COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT, WHICH
MEETS SPECIFIED CRITERIA AND WHO
HAVE NEGOTIATED WITH THEIR LOCAL
UNION TO INCLUDE THE WAIVER IN
THEIR CBA. THE STATUTE DOES NOT
ALTER A LOCAL UNION'S ABILITY TO
DECIDE TO INCLUDE OR NOT INCLUDE
THE PAGA WAIVER IN THEIR CBA, AS
LOCAL CONTROL ON THAT, INCLUDING
THE WAIVER, WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
A SUBJECT OF BARGAINING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BY EACH UNION. WHEN
A LABOR UNION AND AN EMPLOYER IN
THE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES ENTER INTO A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT, EXISTING
LAW PROVIDES THAT THOSE
EMPLOYERS SHALL BE EXEMPT FROM
PAGA, PROVIDED THAT CBA INCLUDES
THE FOLLOWING. PREMIUM WAGE
RATES FOR OVERTIME AN HOURLY
WAGE OF NOT LESS THAN 30%, MORE
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE. A
GRIEVANCE AND BINDING
ARBITRATION PROCEDURE TO REDRESS
VIOLATIONS. A CLEAR WAIVER OF
THE REQUIREMENTS OF PAGA IN
UNAMBIGUOUS TERMS, AND AN
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE ARBITRATOR
TO AWARD ANY AND ALL REMEDIES
AVAILABLE UNDER PAGA SECTION 203
D OF THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
RELATIONS ACT AFFIRMS THAT
RESOLVING LABOR DISPUTES THROUGH
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS IS A DESIRABLE METHOD
FOR SETTLING GRIEVANCE DISPUTES
RELATED TO THE APPLICATION OR
INTERPRETATION OF AN EXISTING
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT.
THIS BILL ALIGNS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL INTENT BY USING
THE WELL-ESTABLISHED COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS TO RESOLVE
PAGA DISPUTES. AB 1034 WILL
ALLOW WORKERS TO CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS IMPORTANT
EXEMPTION BY EXTENDING THE
CURRENT SUNSET IN THE LAW FROM
2028 TO 2038. THE MEASURE IS
SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
AND THE STATE COUNCIL OF LABORS.
AMONG OTHERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CORTESE. ANY DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO.
GALLO. NO ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I
ATKINS. I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER.
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
I DALLEY NÓ DODD DURAZO DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD JONES I DON'T KNOW
LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
NO NILO OCHOA. NO PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE NOW MEMBERS SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE
TIME. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN I EGGMAN.
I GROVE NO NILO. ON A VOTE OF 32
IN FAVOR. SEVEN AGAINST. THE
MEASURE PASSES THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS UP. MEMBERS ARE FILE ITEM
59 AND 81. WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM 59. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
1147. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1147 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OTIS. AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SENATOR
MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AB 1142 ADDS A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUIREMENT TO
REGIONAL CENTERS, WHICH ARE
CURRENTLY NOT SUBJECT TO PUBLIC
RECORDS DISCLOSURES, DESPITE
SERVING A PUBLIC PURPOSE AND
BEING FUNDED WITH GOVERNMENT
DOLLARS, IT WAS GOING TO BRING A
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WORK WITH THOSE
WHO HAVE A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY, RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
DISCUSSION, SAID BRADFORD. NO
OKAY. SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS.
AYES 40. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 81.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 2317.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
ASSEMBLY BILL 2317 BY SENATE
MEMBER STEPHANIE NGUYEN. AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILDCARE FACILITIES
TO SUPPORT AND SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES. MA'AM. SENATOR.
PHENOMENAL. THANK YOU SIR. AB 30
2317 WILL REQUIRE PRIVATE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS WHO OPT IN TO
IMPLEMENT AN ANAPHYLAXIS POLICY
REQUESTING FOR NIVO RESPECTFULLY.
MEMBERS, ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY SENATOR WANT TO BE
HEARD. IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SEEING NO
OBJECTION. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIFTING THE CALL ON ONE ITEM
FILE. ITEM 67. SECRETARY, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. ALVARADO, GIL.
EGGMAN I HURTADO. NÓ. LAIRD I
LIMON. MAN WHEN PORTANTINO. ROTH
RUBIO. CIERTO SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. I WILK I ALVARADO. GIL I.
AYES 23. NOES NINE. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE ARE NOW MOVING INTO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
DURING UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MAJORITY LEADER,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE
ALL MEASURES REPORTED FROM
COMMITTEE BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED AND
ORDERED TO THIRD READING,
PLEASE. SENATOR SENATOR CRESPO,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. A
TANGLED WEB WE WEAVE AGAIN. WE
MUST OBJECT TO THIS. IT JUST
COMPOUNDS THE PREVIOUS ONES THAT
WE ARE ALREADY OBJECTING TO. SO
WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR CIERTO IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ DALLY. NÓ. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
ALVARADO. GILL. I DON'T KNOW.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. GROVE NO.
HURTADO JONES. NO. LAIRD. I
LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CORTEZ AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. HURTADO AYE. AYES 31. NOES
NINE. THE MOTION CARRIES.
SENATOR GLAZER, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WAS GOING TO
REQUEST. I AM REQUESTING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW MY
REQUEST TO MOVE SENATE BILL 1382
TO THE INACTIVE FILE TO
WITHDRAW. SO I'M ASKING FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW MY
MOTION. THERE MY REQUEST. ANY
OBJECTION TO THAT REQUEST?
MEASURE ORDERED TO THE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'M STILL PROCESSING
THE LAST MOTION, BUT I DO HAVE A
MOTION THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE. FILE ITEM 152, SB 892
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE THE DESK HAS NOTED THE
FOLLOWING. MAJORITY LEADER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. PLEASE MOVE
FILE ITEMS 25 AB 2886 AND FILE
ITEM 50 AB 365. AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR TO THE INACTIVE
FILE, THE DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR
CUEVAS, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND I NEED
TO. OH WHERE IS IT? MOVE HERE.
WE GO. ACR OKAY, I GOT TO COME
BACK. I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER.
I'LL COME BACK. ANY OTHER MEMBER,
WISHES TO BE HEARD UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR ALLEN.
YES? I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE AB 233
BY WILSON. MOVED TO THE INACTIVE
FILE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. THE DESK HAS NOTED
SENATOR BECKER, THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO MOVE FILE ITEM 19 ACR
132, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR CUEVAS,
COMING BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MADAM PRESIDENT, I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON ACR 226
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE DESK
IS NOTED. SEE NO MIX UP. WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM 112, FIVE
MINUTES AFTER WE RECESSED. LET'S
GET A QUORUM. LET'S GET IT DONE.
WE HEARD YOU LOUD AND CLEAR,
MADAM CHAIR. ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
CHAIR WISHES TO BE HEARD.
MEMBERS, THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT. WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR. WE WILL BREAK FOR
ONE HOUR FOR LUNCH. PLEASE STAY
IN THE BUILDING SO WE CAN RESUME
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL FILE AND
CONTINUE OUR WORK. AND GET OUT
OF HERE ON TIME. SEE YOU IN AN
HOUR.
ASKING ALL MEMBERS TO RETURN TO
THE FLOOR. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ITEMS COMING UP THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. WE NEED ALL MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR.
FOR. THE NEXT FOUR ON FILE. OUR
FILE ITEM. 9252 138 MEMBERS, WE
NEED YOU ALL BACK ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS. SENATOR PORTANTINO IS
KICKING US OFF. FILE ITEM 92.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2892 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWE. AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES. THAT'S CORRECT.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS, I
RISE TO PRESENT AB 2892 ON
BEHALF OF THE INCOMPARABLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW TRANSPORTATION
COMPANIES WITH 25 OR MORE
VEHICLES TO DEPOSIT CASH OR
SURETY BOND IN LIEU OF THE NET
WORTH REQUIREMENT UNDER CURRENT
LAW, BILL AIMS TO ASSIST
PARATRANSIT, PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
OTHER TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES
IN STABILIZING INCREASING
INSURANCE COSTS. DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES PERMITS DRIVERS
TO USE CASH IN LIEU OF
INSURANCE, AND MANY DRIVERS
ALREADY UTILIZE THE OPTION. THIS
SEEKS TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR, ANY MCS
UP FOR DISCUSSION? THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS.
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 39. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR BERG
HAS FILED ITEM 52. THE
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2885 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER-KAHAN. AN ACT RELATING TO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. SENATOR
BERG, THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. AB 2885 SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES THE DEFINITION FOR
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. THIS
WAS PREVIOUSLY ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND PULLED TO ADDRESS
ISSUES. URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BERG. ANY MEMBER
WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM?
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON ITEM 52? I'M SEEING
NONE. AYES 39. NO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SENATOR ELLENBERG HAS
THE NEXT ONE FILE ITEM 100. ÁP
224. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 224 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT.
SENATOR BERG THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL
SIMPLY EXTENDS THE NEWS CARRIER
EXEMPTION FROM AB FIVE UNTIL
2030. URGE AND I VOTE. ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD. I AM
SEEING NONE. ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL FOR THIS ITEM? AYES 39. NO.
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, NEXT UP IS
ITEM 38 AB. TWO. 693 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. SENATOR PREPARED.
SECRETARY. MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2693 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WICKS AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES AB 2693,
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, WILL GIVE SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS WHO WERE VICTIMIZED IN
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES A
CHANCE TO SEEK JUSTICE IN THE
TOUGH ON CRIME ERA. CALIFORNIA
SENT MORE THAN 130,000 CHILDREN
TO JAILS AND COUNTY JUVENILE
DETENTION CENTERS. TOO MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE COME
FORWARD AS ADULTS NOW TO SHARE
THEIR NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES ON
SEXUAL ASSAULT PERPETRATED BY
EMPLOYEES OF THESE JUVENILE
CAMPS. IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS,
CALIFORNIA HAS EXTENDED THE
CIVIL STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT,
CREATED A THREE YEAR WINDOW FOR
REVIVED CLAIMS OF CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULTS, AND ELIMINATED
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT FOR
ACTIONS ARISING ON OR AFTER
JANUARY 1ST, 2024.
UNFORTUNATELY, HOWEVER, MANY
VICTIMS WHO ENDURED ABUSE IN
COUNTY JUVENILE FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN TURNED AWAY FROM SEEKING
LEGAL REPRESENTATION BECAUSE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
INDIVIDUAL CASES HAS EXPIRED. AB
2693 IS NARROWLY TAILORED THAT
WILL GIVE THESE SURVIVORS OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT THE
ABILITY TO COME FORWARD, REPORT
THEIR ABUSE AND SEEK JUSTICE IN
COURT. BY THE END OF 2025. THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN EVO. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
GROVE? THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN FAVOR OF
THIS, YOU KNOW, DOING RESEARCH
ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING. YOU FIND
OUT THAT GIRLS DON'T EVEN KNOW
THEY'RE BEING TRAFFICKED UNTIL
THEY TURN A LATER AGE. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF WOMEN THAT HAVE
TAKEN THAT NOT TAKING THAT
POSITION, BUT THEY JUST DIDN'T
REALIZE WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
THEM. AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS SO
CRAZY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
BUT IT'S THE SAME THING ABOUT
HAVING THAT TRAUMA TO COME
FORWARD. LIKE, YOU TALK ABOUT
THOSE CHILDREN IN A JUVENILE
FACILITY. I WISH THE BILL WAS
EXPANSIVE ON, YOU KNOW, ALL
CHILDREN BEING AFFECTED IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION. BUT I DO
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE STUFF
ONE STEP AT A TIME AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, BECAUSE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. AND
KIDS THAT ARE ABUSED IN IN THESE
FACILITIES WHEN THEY'RE YOUNGER
AND JUST LIKE THE BILL WE DID.
1043 WHEN YOU'RE ABUSED, WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNGER, THEY HAVE TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DIGEST
THAT, RECOGNIZE WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM AND KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A
SAFE PLACE TO COME FORWARD AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE, THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD, FOR RISING AND
SHARING HER SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL, RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE. RIGHT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 38. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. LAIRD. AYE.
LEHMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLI JONES. MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN. I'M GOING TO CLOSE IT.
SENATOR MENGIBAR MOVES THE CALL.
SENATORS, WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE FOR UNDER
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. THE NEXT
THREE UP ARE FILE ITEM ONE, 81,
81 AND 182. SENATOR UMBERG HAS
FILED ITEM 180. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 336 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO STATE GRANTS. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. S.B. 336 AND ITS
COMPANION MEASURE BY SENATOR
LEMON. BRING CALIFORNIA ON PAR
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BY
ENSURING THAT OUR NONPROFIT
AGENCIES ARE FAIRLY AND
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED FOR THE
IMPORTANT WORK THEY DO FOR US AS
A STATE. THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY CLARIFY SOME
DEFINITIONS, REMOVE REQUIREMENTS
ON DGS, AND ALLOW FOR SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN THE DE MINIMIS
RATE FOR NEGOTIATIONS. URGE AND
I VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
UMBERG. ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE
HEARD ON THIS ITEM? ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. SENATOR
PADILLA IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ITEM 181. SENATE
BILL 583 BY SENATOR PADILLA. AN
ACT RELATING TO HUMAN SERVICES.
SENATOR PADILLA. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TO PRESENT SB 583, WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE SALTON SEA
CONSERVANCY. THE AMENDMENTS
REFLECT AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE CONSERVANCY AND MAKE IT
CONTINGENT ON THE PASSAGE OF THE
BOND. IT HAS HAD BROAD, BROAD,
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. ZERO. NO
VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
PADILLA, ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE
HEARD? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALI
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
DALY. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYES 39. NØ
ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR CORTEZ,
YOU HAVE FILED ITEM 182.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 636 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION. SENATOR. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATORS, SB 636 REQUIRES A
PHYSICIAN TO BE LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THEY MAKE A
MODIFICATION OR DENIAL TO A
PRIVATE WORKER'S COMP CLAIM.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS REMOVED A
PROVISION REQUIRING UTILIZATION
REVIEWERS TO HAVE THE SAME DUTY
OF CARE TO PATIENTS AS THEY DO
AS WOULD TREATING PHYSICIANS.
THIS IS BACK ON CONCURRENCY.
AMENDMENTS ALSO REMOVED TWO CODE
SECTIONS FROM THE BILL TO STATE
ITS GOAL AS CLEARLY AND AS
SIMPLY AS POSSIBLE. IT WAS
AMENDED TO DELAY THE EFFECTIVE
DATE TO JULY 1ST, 2026. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE.
ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLE AND FILE ITEM 182.
ALAN Ã ALVARADO NØ ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY NÓ DODD I DURAZO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. HURTADO GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN.
MEN I NEWMAN, I NGUYEN. NO NILO.
NO. OCHOA. BOGH NO. PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO.
SEYARTO NO. SKINNER RUBIO I
SKINNER. I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
STERN, I UMBERG, I WAHAB I
WIENER. I WILK. NO. AYES 30.
NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. SENATOR EGGMAN
HAS FILED ITEM 183. YOUR SB 1025
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1025 BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO VETERAN DIVERSION. SENATOR
EGGMAN SB 1025 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE, HAVING TO DO WITH
VETERAN DIVERSION. I ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. ANY DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN, I ALVARADO
GILL I ARCHULETA. I ASHBY, I
ATKINS, I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I
DALLEY DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I LEHMAN I
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN
I NGUYEN I NILO OCHOA PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLEY JONES, MCGUIRE.
NILO OCHOA. BOGH SUGIARTO. AYES
34. NÓ ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NEXT UP ARE
ITEM 184, 185 AND 187. SENATOR
BIXBY IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1053 BY
SENATOR BREAKSPEARE. AN ACT TO
SOLID WASTE. SENATOR BLAKE SPEER
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 1053 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AT THE GROCERY
STORE. CONSUMERS CAN EITHER
PURCHASE A RECYCLED PAPER BAG OR
BRING THEIR OWN REUSABLE BAG. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
FOR NOMINAL SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION? SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I. ALVARADO,
GIL ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS,
I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
DALLEY DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
HURTADO I JONES. NØ. LAIRD I
LEHMAN I MAGUIRE MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA. NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO
I ROTH I RUBIO I CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I GROVE. NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO
GILL. NO CORTEZ I DALLEY. NO.
MCGUIRE. AYES 31 EIGHT. NO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED
IN. SENATOR PADILLA HAS FILED
ITEM 185. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1105 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING
TO PAID SICK LEAVE. SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SB 1105 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE, WHICH EXPANDS
EXISTING PAID LEAVE TO ALLOW
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYERS TO WORK.
EMPLOYEES EXCUSE ME, WHO WORK
OUTSIDE TO USE THEIR CURRENTLY
ENTITLED PAID SICK DAYS TO AVOID
SMOKE, HEAT OR FLOODING
CONDITIONS. THE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE ASSEMBLY CLARIFY THAT THIS
DOES NOT CONSTITUTE A CHANGE IN,
BUT IS DECLARATORY OF EXISTING
LAW. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT SICK
LEAVE SICK DAYS ARE NECESSARY
FOR PREVENTIVE CARE AS PROVIDED
FOR IN THE LABOR CODE. THE BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON
THIS ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
AYE. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO.
LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NILO AYE. OCHOA.
BOG. AYE PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SEYARTO. NØ SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLEY
GROVE. AYE MCGUIRE. NGUYEN DALY.
AYES 36. NOES TWO. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR LIMON PHÐ. ITEM EIGHT
187. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1220 BY SENATOR
LIMON. AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
CONTRACTS. SENATOR. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS SB ONE 1220 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT THE QUALITY OF PUBLIC
SERVICES BY REQUIRING HUMAN
WORKERS TO REMAIN IN CALL
CENTERS FOR GOVERNMENT BENEFIT
PROGRAMS, INSTEAD OF BEING
OUTSOURCED TO ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR, ANY MEMBER WISH TO BE
HEARD. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL NO. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALI. NO. DODD AYE. DURAZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLASER MCGUIRE. AYES 30. NOS. Ã
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THE NEXT THREE ON
DECK ARE FOR ITEM 188, 189 AND
190. SENATOR WILK IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1233 BY SENATOR WILK. AN
ACT RELATING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SENATOR WILK, THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. SB 1233 IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE. HAPPY TO
REPORT THE ASSEMBLY DIDN'T SCREW
IT UP. TOO BAD. THIS MEASURE
ESTABLISHES A CURRICULUM
FRAMEWORK FOR A MORE EFFICIENT
SPAY NEUTER PROCESS TO BE
ADOPTED BY CALIFORNIA'S
VETERINARIAN SCHOOLS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I'M VERY HAPPY FOR YOU,
SENATOR. SOME OF US WEREN'T AS
LUCKY AS YOU. ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL? SEEING NONE. AYES 39. NÓ
ZERO. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR IS COMING. YOU HAVE PHÐ
ITEM 189. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1277 BY
SENATOR STERN. AN ACT RELATING
TO PUPIL INSTRUCTION. SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT TRAINING TEACHERS
TO CLOSE SOME VERY WIDE DIVIDES
IN OUR SOCIETY AND FIND SOME
COMMON GROUND. THIS TEACHERS
COLLABORATIVE ON HOLOCAUST AND
GENOCIDE EDUCATION HAS BEEN UP
AND RUNNING IN THE STATE FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS, AND IT'S AN
INSPIRING CROSS-SECTION OF
VOICES THAT OFTEN DON'T GET
HEARD, NOT JUST SURVIVORS OF THE
HOLOCAUST, BUT VOICES FROM THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE TO THE RWANDAN
GENOCIDE TO THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE. AND IT ALSO MAKES
CLEAR THAT SHOULD IN THE FUTURE
THE UN DEEM OTHER ATROCITIES
ACTUAL GENOCIDES, THAT THOSE
WILL ALSO BE AT LEAST ELIGIBLE
FOR CONSIDERATION IN THE
MATERIAL THAT IS BROUGHT TO
THESE TEACHERS. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT CURRICULUM, THOUGH, TO BE
CLEAR, AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE STATE HAS ACTUALLY
JUST GOING TO PROVIDE THESE
KINDS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TEACHERS. THIS RANGES FROM YOUR
ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHERS WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR THESE KINDS OF
VOICES TO A SOCIAL STUDIES OR A
MATH TEACHER. I'VE BEEN TO THESE
COLLABORATIVES AND I WILL TELL
YOU, THE INTERNET MAKES US FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON
SOME DAYS AND THAT, AND THAT WE
SHOULD ALL BRING OUR POLITICS
RIGHT INTO THAT CLASSROOM. AND
THEY JUST FIND A WAY, THROUGH
THEIR EXPERIENCES AND THROUGH
THESE VOICES THAT WE'RE BRINGING
TO THE TABLE TO MAKE A DIFFERENT
KIND OF EDUCATION FOR OUR
CLASSROOM AND BRING TO LIFE
THINGS THAT ARE AT RISK OF
DYING. 67% OF MILLENNIALS IN
THIS COUNTRY DON'T KNOW WHAT
AUSCHWITZ WAS. NEVER EVEN 50% OF
GEN Z HAS NEVER EVEN HEARD OF
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THE
HOLOCAUST. AND THIS IS PERSONAL,
I KNOW, FOR EVERYBODY. SO WE ALL
COME FROM SOMEWHERE, AND
HOPEFULLY THIS BILL BRINGS THAT
TO THE FORE AND MAKES IT A
LITTLE DIFFERENT FUTURE FOR OUR
CLASSROOMS AND FOR OUR TEACHERS,
BECAUSE I REALLY DO THINK THEY
ARE THE SOLUTION. SO WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE,
SENATOR GROVE. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM PRESIDENT, I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 1277, AND
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAYS ON FOX NEWS, I'M
JESSE WATERS, DOES A MAN ON THE
STREET THING. AND RIGHT BEFORE
OCTOBER SEVENTH, HE WAS OUT
THERE ON THE STREET GOING, HEY,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE HOLOCAUST
IS? DO YOU KNOW WHAT THIS. DO
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS. AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SAID, 66% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION DID NOT KNOW. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS THAT
NUMBER, BUT PROBABLY ONE OUT OF,
YOU KNOW, ONE OUT OF TWO DID NOT
KNOW WHAT THE HOLOCAUST WAS. AND
THAT'S A PRETTY SCARY THOUGHT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT JUST RANDOM
PEOPLE ON THE STREET THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN OUR HISTORY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK? ANY OTHER
MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR STERN, YOU GET TO
CLOSE NOW. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, ONE LAST THING I DID
WANT TO CLARIFY FOR THOSE WITH
SOME QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW, THERE
HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS RAISED BY
THE VERY LIMITED NUMBER OF FOLKS
IN OPPOSITION THAT SOMEHOW THIS
WILL BE, A JEWISH CONTROLLED
COLLABORATIVE, THAT JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS OR JEWISH ALIGNED
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD SOMEHOW
CONTROL THIS, I'D SAY AT FIRST
IT'S A IT'S A DANGEROUS KIND OF
LANGUAGE TO USE BECAUSE IT, IT
FEEDS INTO SOME TROPES AND
STEREOTYPES THAT I THINK WE
REALLY NEED TO GET AWAY FROM.
BUT SECONDLY, IF YOU READ THE
LANGUAGE IN THE LEGISLATION,
THIS PUTS THIS PROGRAM INTO THE
STATE, INTO THE STATE. SO THERE
IS NO ONE ORGANIZATION CALLED
OUT INTO THE BILL, TO RUN THIS
OPERATION. IN FACT, THE CROSS
SECTION RUNS FROM INDIGENOUS
AMERICAN GROUPS TO ARMENIAN
GROUPS. IT'S A COLLABORATIVE
THAT'S LITERALLY THE DESIGN OF
THE BILL. SO I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS THE AUTHOR'S INTENT AS
WELL AS THE TEXT OF THE BILL.
HAS THAT IN THERE. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM?
AYES 39. NO ZERO. DISREGARD.
DISREGARD WE HAVE AN OBJECTION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL NO.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. ALVARADO.
GIL. NO. TO AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYE
AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR ALLEN, YOU HAVE PHÐ.
ITEM 190. YOU ARE READY TO GO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1297 BY SENATOR ALLEN. AN
ACT RELATING TO VEHICLES.
SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. IT CREATES A SPEED
CAMERA PILOT PROGRAM FOR A
PARTICULAR STRETCH OF ROAD IN
THE CITY OF MALIBU, THE PCH,
WHERE DOZENS HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
THE PAST FEW YEARS. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS WERE CLARIFYING. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR, ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON FINAL
ITEM 190. SECRETARY, LET'S GO
AHEAD AND CALL THAT ROLL. ALLEN
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL NO. ARCHULETA
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO
NO. OCHOA. NO PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
SEYARTO. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA. AYE. DALY.
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYES 35. NOES FOUR.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN SENATORS THIS WEEK.
WE'VE HAD A WONDERFUL GUEST.
COME AND JOIN US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR AMAZING PARKING ATTENDANTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES WHO ARE HERE IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBERS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WHAT YOU ALL DO.
SENATORS, WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
GROUP PHOTO WITH THESE HARD
WORKING INDIVIDUALS IN THE BACK.
IF YOU WISH TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE GROUP PHOTO.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE NEXT. THE
THREE NEXT ITEMS ARE FILE ITEM
191, 192 AND 193. SENATOR LIMÓN
HAS FILED ITEM 191. RIGHT.
COLLEAGUES, WE ARE BACK. WE ARE
BACK. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1304 BY SENATOR
LYMAN. AN ACT RELATING TO OIL
AND GAS. SENATOR LYMAN. THANK
YOU. SB 1304 IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. THE BILL ENSURES
THAT PUBLIC THE PUBLIC HAS
ACCESS TO INFORMATION GATHERED
BY CAL JAM AND THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD RELATED
TO EXEMPTING AN UNDERGROUND
WATER AQUIFER FOR OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY MEMBER WISH
TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALY
NÓ. DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE.
LYMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN WHEN. NO.
NILO. NO. OCHOA. BOGH. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO A ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HURTADO. NO MCGUIRE. NEWMAN.
AYES 28. NOES TEN. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. THE
NEXT COUPLE ITEMS. WE'RE GOING
TO BE PUTTING ON CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL
ONLY ONCE. SENATOR ARCHULETA,
YOU HAVE ITEM 192. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1315 BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATE BILL 1315 IS
ON CONCURRENT SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY ANNUAL REPORTING.
I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. I SEE NO MIX UP.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN Ã ALVARADO. GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OCHOA. BOGH. AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE.
SENATOR ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
MOVES TO CALL. SENATOR BRADFORD
HAS FILED ITEM 193. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1328 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. 1323
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE BILL
WILL UPDATE AND MAKE CLEAR
EXISTING LAW PROCEDURES AND
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO ELECTION
TECHNOLOGY CERTIFIED FOR USE IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. ANY MEMBER
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
HAS THE URGENCY CLAUSE REQUIRES
27 VOTES. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO, GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. AYE. ECKMAN.
AYE. GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE
SENATOR BRADFORD MOVES THE CALL.
I SEE HOW WE'RE ALL SITTING AT
OUR DESKS. WE'RE VERY DEMURE.
SOME WOULD SAY WE'RE VERY
MINDFUL. SENATOR CUEVAS HAS
FILED ITEM 194. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ Ó. THANK YOU. SENATE BILL
1340 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. AN ACT RELATING TO
DISCRIMINATION. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, TODAY
I PRESENT SB 1340. THE BILL HAS
BEEN AMENDED TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION. 1340 WOULD ALLOW FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS OF DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE AND IN HOUSING
UPON STATE CIVIL RIGHTS,
ISSUANCE OF A RIGHT TO SUE
LETTER. ALL OTHER SECTIONS OF
THE BILL RELATING TO FEDERAL
CONTRACTING, TRACKING AND
REPORTING HAVE BEEN REMOVED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR ANY
MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLE ONCE ALLEN Ã ALVARADO. GIL
NÓ ARCHULETA I. ASHBY. I.
ATKINS. I. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER
BECKER. I BLAKE. SPEER. I
BRADFORD I. CABALLERO CORTEZ. I
TALLEY. NÓ. DODD I. DURAZZO. I
EGGMAN. I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. NØ. HURTADO I JONES. NÓ
LAIRD I LEHMAN I MCGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I'M IN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN NO NILO. NO. OCHOA, NO.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. NO SKINNER, I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG I WAHAB, I WIENER, I WILK.
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL.
ONE MORE TIME. CABALLERO I WILK
NO AYES 31, NOES NINE. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR BECKER,
YOU HAVE FILE ITEM 195.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1374 BY SENATOR BECKER. AN
ACT TO ENERGY. SENATOR BECKER, I
THANK YOU. 1374 IS BACK. I WAS A
REMINDER. THIS IS A BILL THAT
JUST TREATS COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS
EXACTLY AS WHAT THE PUC DID FOR
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS. THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO THREE
THINGS. ONE, THEY STATE THAT
SCHOOLS AND MULTIFAMILY ARE
EXPLICITLY INCLUDED IN
SELF-CONSUMPTION. AGAIN, LIKE
RESIDENTIAL UNITS, IT REQUIRES
THIS. SECONDLY, THAT THE PUC
WILL DETERMINE WHAT OTHER SETS
OF METERS ARE CLOSE ENOUGH IN
PROXIMITY E.G. RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS, NONPROFITS, CIVIC
CENTERS, SOME FARMS TO BE
CONSIDERED SELF-CONSUMPTION. AND
THIRD, WE ADDED A SUNSET, WHICH
WE DID IN GOOD FAITH TO SO WE
CAN SEE THE EFFECT. IF THIS DOES
HAVE ANY EFFECT ON RATES, THE
MEASURE WILL PUT MONEY BACK INTO
CLASSROOMS AND ON THE TABLES OF
KITCHEN TABLES OF THOSE WHO LIVE
IN MULTIFAMILY APARTMENTS. I'LL
NOTE THAT SINCE THE CPUC RULING,
SOLAR ON MULTIFAMILY IS DOWN
96%, DOWN 96% SINCE THE CPUC
MADE THIS ILL ADVISED RULING AND
THIS WILL AGAIN CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR BUILDING OWNERS
AND RESIDENTS IN THOSE BUILDINGS
WILL BENEFIT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I AM SEEING NO
MIKES UP FOR DISCUSSION.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. NO.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY. NØ.
DODD. DURAZO AYE. EGGMAN GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. DODD. AYE. LEHMAN. AYE.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN. WHEN NO. NILO. NO.
OCHOA. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO CIERTO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. EGGMAN NO.
GROVE NO. JONES NO! MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN OCHOA. RUBIO AYE. AYES
27. NOES NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXT, THREE ARE GOING TO BE 196.
FILE NUMBER 197 AND 198. SENATOR
ASHBY IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1498 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING
TO CANNABIS. SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SB 1498.
THIS IS THE CANNABIS AND
INDUSTRIAL HEMP ADVERTISING ACT.
SB 1498 ALLOWS ENFORCEMENT FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, COUNTY
COUNCIL, OR A CITY ATTORNEY WHEN
A CANNABIS OR HEMP LICENSEE OR
AN ILLICIT BUSINESS IS IN
VIOLATION OF CURRENT ADVERTISING
LAWS DESIGNED TO PROTECT YOUTH.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS EXPAND
THE BILL TO ENFORCE INDUSTRIAL
HEMP AND MAKE A FEW TECHNICAL
CHANGES. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM? ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40
AND NO. ZERO. THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
SENATOR STERN, YOU HAVE FILED
ITEM 187. SENATOR STERN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1505 BY SENATOR STERN. AN
ACT RELATING TO SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. WE'VE TAKEN
SOME AMENDMENTS IN THE ASSEMBLY
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CYBERBULLYING. CURRENTLY, WHEN
CYBERBULLYING ATTACKS ARE
EXPERIENCED ONLINE, OFTEN YOU
REPORT THE INCIDENTS. BUT SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANIES ARE REALLY UNDER
NO LEGAL OBLIGATION TO RESPOND.
AND OFTEN THOSE FLAGS FALL ON
DEAF EARS AND THEY GO OFF INTO
THE ETHER AND MEANWHILE,
CHILDREN LIKE ONE IN LOS ANGELES
IN THE PAST MONTH WHO HAD
MULTIPLE INCIDENTS WHERE SHE WAS
BEAT UP AT SCHOOL, PUT ON THESE
FIGHT PAGES AND KIDS JUST
WATCHED THOSE VIDEOS ON A LOOP.
SHE IS NO LONGER WITH US. THE
FINAL FIGHT WAS A DEADLY ONE,
AND SHE'S GONE. AND YOUNG PEOPLE
THESE DAYS ARE EXPERIENCING AN
EPIDEMIC WITH CYBERBULLYING. SO
FINALLY, WE THINK THAT THIS
CREATES A FRAMEWORK THAT THE
TECH COMPANIES WILL HAVE SOME
OBLIGATION TO RESPOND AND THAT
OUR TEACHERS, OUR
ADMINISTRATORS, NOT JUST
STUDENTS, BUT THEIR PARENTS ALSO
ARE GOING TO HAVE SOME RECOURSE
TO GET A RESPONSE. BUT WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK, FROM THE
INDUSTRY SIDE TO FIND MECHANISMS
FOR THIS REPORTING THAT CAN
ACTUALLY WORK WITH THEIR
EXISTING PLATFORMS. AND I THINK
WE'VE LANDED SOMETHING HERE THAT
IS GOING TO ACTUALLY WORK IN LAW.
SO THIS IS A CRISIS. WE NEED
THIS. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY MEMBER WISH
TO BE HEARD. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALY. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN. NILO. AYE. OKUBO AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO ACIERTO. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DOLLY
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE JONES.
MCGUIRE. AYE. WHEN? AYE SEYARTO.
WAHAB AYE. AYES 36. NO. ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. SENATOR GLASER'S
PREPARED FOR THE NEXT FILE ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ITEM 188,
SENATE BILL 1382 BY SENATOR
GLASER. AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH AND CARE FACILITIES.
SENATOR GLASER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ALLOW
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY TO CREATE BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT ARE AT LEAST AS
STRINGENT AS PRIMARY CARE
CLINICS IN CALIFORNIA, WHEN NOT
AS REQUIRED. WHEN RECEIVING
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENTS FOR THAT
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
I SEE NO MICS UP FOR DISCUSSION.
ANY OBJECTION FOR UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS FOR UTILIZING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? AYES 40. NÓ
ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. COLLEAGUES, THERE
ARE TWO MORE ITEMS ON THIS LIST.
THERE ARE FIVE ITEM EIGHT AND
FIVE. ITEM 186. SENATOR
CABALLERO HAS FILED ITEM EIGHT.
SECRETARY SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1432 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
SENATOR CABALLERO. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1431, WHICH IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. I'M GOING TO
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR A
LENGTHY DISCOURSE, BUT IT HAS
BEEN SAID THAT WE HAVE NOT
NEGOTIATED, AND THOSE THAT KNOW
ME, KNOW, KNOW, KNOW THAT I
NEGOTIATE THE HELL OUT OF MY
BILLS. SO I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN DURING THE PENDENCY
OF THIS BILL. THE BILL PROVIDES
MORE TRANSPARENCY,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND AUTHORITY TO
HK TO ENSURE ALL HOSPITALS, ALL
HOSPITALS REACH SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE. WE MADE A REAL
ATTEMPT TO CREATE A FRAMEWORK
THAT HOSPITALS HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO GET
AN EXTENSION. THE BILL ENSURES
THE FOLLOWING. NO AUTOMATIC
EXTENSION FOR A HOSPITAL. IF YOU
CAN MEET THE DEADLINE BY 2030.
DISCRETIONARY AUTHORITY TO HK TO
APPROVE, MODIFY OR DENY AN
APPLICATION FOR AN EXTENSION AND
HK ONLY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE AN EXTENSION FOR 1 TO 5
YEARS DEPENDING ON THE
PARTICULAR NEED OF THE HOSPITAL.
REQUIRES ALL HOSPITALS APPLYING
FOR AN EXTENSION TO DEMONSTRATE
A FINANCIAL PATHWAY TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE, AND TO KEEP THE
HEALTH SERVICES ONGOING WHILE
THEY'RE DOING THEIR SEISMIC
RETROFITTING. THE EXTENSION
APPLICATION REQUIRES SAFETY AND
EMERGENCY PLANNING TO ENSURE
PATIENT AND STAFF STAFF SAFETY
IN THE EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE,
AND ALL SEISMIC COMPLIANCE PLANS
AND NONSTRUCTURAL PERFORMANCE
CATEGORY FIVE EVALUATIONS MUST
BE APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
ENSURE PATIENT AND WORKER
SAFETY. IF HK APPROVES ANY
REQUEST FOR AN EXTENSION,
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO HOLD THE
HOSPITALS ACCOUNTABLE TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT. MILESTONES
AND IF A HOSPITAL MISSES THE
MILESTONE, THEN HK CAN FIND THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM ON A DAILY BASIS
PER BED UNTIL THEY COMPLETE THE
MILESTONES THEY HAVE TO. ONCE
THE HOSPITALS SUBMIT THEIR
APPLICATION FOR AN EXTENSION,
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
COPY OF THE OF THEIR APPLICATION
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE CITY COUNCIL. ALL LABOR
UNIONS WHO REPRESENT WORKERS IN
THE HOSPITAL. THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND THE STATE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. IN
ADDITION, BEFORE PROCESSING THAT
APPLICATION, THE COMMUNITY HAS
45 DAYS FOR A COMMENT PERIOD
PRIOR TO HK. HK APPROVING,
DENYING OR MODIFYING ANY
EXTENSION. THE COMPLIANCE
SCHEDULE HAS TO INCLUDE THE
PERMITS, THE CONSTRUCTION PLANS,
THE COMMENCEMENT DATE OF THE
PROJECT, COMPLETION DATES,
FINANCING A TON OF INFORMATION
THAT HAS TO BE PROVIDED TO THE
COMMUNITY. THEY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE AUDITED
FINANCIALS WITH ATTESTATION
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY. THAT
THE REQUEST AND THE FINANCIALS
ARE TRUE. IF THE HOSPITALS FAIL
TO MEET THEIR MILESTONES OR
SEISMIC COMPLIANCE, THEY WILL
NOT BE ISSUED A BUILDING PERMIT
FOR ANY OTHER BUILDING IN THE
FACILITY. IF HOSPITALS MISS A
MILESTONE OR VIOLATE ANY OF THE
AGREEMENTS WITH HK, THERE'S AN
ENFORCEMENT. ANY ENFORCEMENT
ACTION HAS TO BE POSTED ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S WEBSITE ALONG WITH
WHAT THE WHAT THE SOLUTION WAS
AND WHAT THE PENALTY WOULD BE.
THE WEBSITE POSTING STARTS IN
2028 AND ANNUALLY WITH DETAILED
DATA OF THE APPROVED COMPLIANT
PLANS. THE PLANS, THE DECISION
OF HK AND DEADLINES FOR
COMPLIANCE. THIS BILL GOT MORE
ROBUST AS IT TRAVELED THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR. I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. SENATOR NIELLO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THIS
BILL HAS BEEN THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM MERCED HAS NEGOTIATED THE
HELL OUT OF THIS, AND I WOULD
INVITE HER TO, ALONG WITH ME,
NEGOTIATE THE HELL OUT OF
EARTHQUAKE STANDARDS. GENERALLY,
THIS IS AN IRRITATION ON MY
PART. SACRAMENTO, ONE OF OUR
BUSINESS STRENGTHS IS THAT
SACRAMENTO IS AN EARTHQUAKE FREE
ZONE. WE DON'T HAVE EARTHQUAKES
HERE, AND WHETHER YOU'RE LOCATED
IN SACRAMENTO ON THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT OR OVER IN HUMBOLDT OR
DOWN IN SAN DIEGO, YOU HAVE TO
MEET THE SAME EARTHQUAKE
STANDARDS FOR HOSPITALS.
REGARDLESS, THE RISK VARIES
TREMENDOUSLY AROUND THE STATE,
BUT WE HAVE, AS WE DO WITH TOO
MUCH LEGISLATION HERE. SOMEBODY
SEES A PROBLEM IN ONE AREA AND
THEY WANT TO FIX IT, AND IT
APPLIES TO EVERYBODY. THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENT APPLIES TO
EVERYBODY, AND IT MAKES NO SENSE.
SO LET'S GET TOGETHER AND
NEGOTIATE THE HELL OUT OF THAT
ONE SIZE FITS ALL. BUT I URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS. ANY OTHER
MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM? IT SOUNDS LIKE IT. SENATOR
CABALLERO, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MEMBERS, FOR
LISTENING TO ME TODAY. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS, RIGHT NOW, THE
WAY WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
IS ONE OFFS. WHENEVER SOMEONE'S
NOT GOING TO MEET THE SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE, WE DO IT. ONE
HOSPITAL AT A TIME. AND THIS
BILL PROVIDES US WITH THE
STRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO PUSH
HOSPITALS TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND TO DO IT IN A PUBLIC WAY,
BECAUSE THE REALITY OF THE
SITUATION IS, IF WE DON'T DO
THIS, THEN WE ARE STUCK WITH THE
ONE OFF SITUATION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE BACK HERE IN IN A
NUMBER OF YEARS TRYING TO DO
EACH ONE SEPARATELY WITHOUT THE
STRUCTURE TO SAY, WE NEED TO
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT, WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH YOUR RESOURCES. SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CABALLERO, ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM? SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ALVARADO. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. DALY AYE.
DODD. AYE. DURAZO. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOGH.
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE.
GROVE. AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. THAT WAS AN
AYE. ATKINS AYE. CORTEZ DURAZO.
GLAZER LAIRD. LIMON MEN. PADILLA
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. AYE. DID WE GET THAT? AYE
FROM THE 41ST SENATOR IN THE
GALLERY. AYES 31. NO, ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO DO
ONE EXTRA ONE ON THIS LIST. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE FILE ITEM 78.
SENATOR UMBERG. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 1008
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
AN ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES. AB
1008 CLARIFIES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVACY LAWS APPLY TO PERSONAL
INFORMATION, REGARDLESS OF HOW
THAT INFORMATION IS STORED,
INCLUDING IN THE FORM OF
GENERATIVE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. I URGE AND I VOTE.
ANY MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM? SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. NØ DODD. DURAZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. GROVE. NO.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LIMON AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
NO. NILO. NO. OCHOA. NO.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
NO. NO. SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
AYE. ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
DODD. AYE. GLAZER NEWMAN. I
HEARD SOMETHING FROM THE BACK.
ALVARADO. GILL. NO. WE GOT
ANOTHER NO VOTE OUT THERE. OKAY.
OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
GLAZER NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT. AYES
29, NOES NINE. THE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO OUR FINAL ITEM ON THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. AND THAT
WOULD BE FILE ITEM 186 SB 1112
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. AND I SEE
THAT SHE'S READY. SO SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1112 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR AN ACT RELATING
TO CHILDCARE. SENATOR, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 1112
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE DEEPLY
NARROWED. THE BILL. RIGHT. SO
CURRENTLY IT'S GOING TO CODIFY
IN STATUTE THAT ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT AGENCIES, ALSO KNOWN AS
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL NETWORKS,
CAN USE THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO GET YOUTH
CONNECTED TO DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS. RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP, THIS
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTIONS. AYES
40. NOES ZERO. AND THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THESE ARE THE TWO WE HAVE. NEXT
ITEM 24 AND FIVE. ITEM 43.
SENATOR UMBERG IS READY TO GO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2677 BY SENATE MEMBER CHEN.
AN ACT TO CHARITIES. SENATOR
UMBERG. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE AGGRIEVED CONSUMERS WILL
HAVE RECOURSE AVAILABLE TO
RECOVER THEIR LOSSES UP TO THE
AMOUNT OF THE BOND FOR ACTIONS
OR INACTIONS OF SOMEONE WHO HAS,
IN ESSENCE, VIOLATED THE
CONDITIONS FOR WHICH THE BOND IS
PROVIDED. URGENT. I VOTE ANY
MEMBER WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO GILL.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. NO. MIN
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NHIÀU.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SEYARTO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB. NÓ. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE. SENATOR UMBERG MOVES THE
CALL. SENATOR WILK, YOU HAVE
FILED ITEM 43. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. THE ASSEMBLY BILL 2277 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN WALLACE AND ANDY, I
PRESENT AB 2277, WHICH ALLOWS
PART TIME FACULTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS TO INCREASE
THEIR TERM ASSIGNMENTS FROM 67%
TO 85%, WHICH IS THE LEVEL OF A
FULL TIME FACULTY MEMBER WITH
THE CURRENT CAP PART TIME
PROFESSORS MUST TRAVEL BETWEEN
MULTIPLE CAMPUSES TO ACCUMULATE
FULL TIME TERM ASSIGNMENTS. BY
RAISING THE CAP, PART TIME
PROFESSORS CAN REMAIN ON ONE
CAMPUS AND FOCUS ON SERVING
STUDENTS RATHER THAN COMMUTING.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO BE HEARD ON THIS ITEM?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALY. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. GONZALEZ
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEHMAN
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR I'M
IN. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA. AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SEYARTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE. SENATOR WILK MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK PAUSE. RIGHT NOW. SENATORS
MAYBE NOT SO QUICK.
SENATORS, HERE'S THE GAME PLAN
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US.
WE'RE GIVEN SOME TIME. WE'RE
RECONCILING THE PAPERWORK. WE
HAVE A COUPLE OF CALLS, A COUPLE
BILLS ON CALL. WE NEED TO PRINT
THOSE OUT, AFTER WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO ASK ALL MEMBERS TO STAY
ON THE FLOOR SO WE CAN GET
THROUGH THOSE BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL. THEN WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
TEN MINUTE BREAK AFTER THAT.
WHEN WE COME BACK AFTER THAT TEN
MINUTE BREAK, WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH, THOSE CONSENT ITEMS
SHOULD GO FAIRLY SOON. OUR DAY
SHOULD BE OVER SOON. KNOCK ON
WOOD.
MEMBERS WERE BACK. PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR. WE'RE GOING TO BE
LIFTING CALLS.
WE GOT 13 BILLS ON CALL. LET'S
GET THROUGH THEM. SECRETARY,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM TEN. DODD MCGUIRE. Ã,
PLEASE GO THROUGH THE ROLL. ONE
MORE TIME. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
DODD I. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL FOR FILE ITEM 11. ALAN
ARCHULETA I DODD I HURTADO I
MCGUIRE I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYES 29. NO'S NINE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL FOR FILE
ITEM 12. DODD I GROVE NØ MCGUIRE
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I AYES 32.
NOS. Ã. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 13. DODD I
MCGUIRE. I OCHOA. I 35. NILO NØ
TO I. AYES 36. NOES THREE.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 14.
DODD I MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I AYES
40. NØ ZERO. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. LET'S CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 15.
TALLY I DODD I MCGUIRE, I
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I DON'T KNOW.
AYES 39. NOES ONE. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
FILE ITEM 27. DODD I HURTADO I
MCGUIRE. I. AYES 40 ZERO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES. LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL FOR ITEM 31. DODD I DURAZZO.
I LIMON. MCGUIRE I LIMON I WAHAB
I AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 38. DALLEY
JONES. MCGUIRE. I NEWMAN. I.
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. DALLEY JONES I JONES. I.
AYES 39. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. ITS CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 192. BLAKE
SPEER I CABALLERO I MCGUIRE. I
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL FOR FINAL
ITEM 193. ALAN, I CABALLERO I
DALLEY MCGUIRE I WHEN. DALLY.
DALLY. NÓ WHEN. AYES 38. NOES
ONE. ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM 24.
ALVARADO, GILL DURAZO GLAZER, I
LIMON. MAN ALVARADO. GILL I MEN.
NO NILO. AYES 34. NOES THREE.
MEASURE PASSES. FINAL ITEM ON
CALL. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE AND
FILE ITEM 43. EGGMAN I GLAZER I.
AYES 40. NÓ ZERO. MEASURE PASSES.
I SEE YOU, SENATOR. GIVE ME ONE
MINUTE. 30S.
WE'RE MOVING INTO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I'D LIKE TO FIRST
RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
THERE IS A RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 10.5 FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL 3264. THESE
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE. I URGE YOUR
ADOPTION OF THE RESOLUTION.
SENATOR. YOUR SENATOR. CIERTO.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED MEMBERS. WE
HAVE GROWN WEARY OF OPPOSING
THESE MOTIONS, BUT WE ARE GOING
TO TRY IT. ONE MORE TIME. WE
OPPOSE THIS MOTION. WE DON'T
LIKE WAVING RULES. WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE RULE FOLLOWERS AND HOPE
THAT THIS IS THE LAST ONE THAT
WE MUST OPPOSE. WE ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR CIERTO IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ RESOLVE THAT JOINT RULE
10.5. BE DISPENSED WITH.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN Ã ALVARADO GILL. NO.
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY I ATKINS. I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER. I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY NØ
DODD I DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE HURTADO I
JONES. NO LAIRD I LEHMAN I
MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I'M IN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN NO. NILO NO
OCHOA NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO I SATO. NO. SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I STERN, I
UMBERG, I WAHAB, I WIENER, I
WILK. NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROVE. AYES 31 NO'S A
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
WE'RE NOW MOVING INTO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. NUMBER
47, WHICH ARE ITEMS 115 THROUGH
143 AND SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER 49, WHICH ARE ITEMS 144
THROUGH 179. DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO PULL AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDARS? SEEING NONE?
LOOKING FOR A SECOND? WE ARE NOW
IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR PART OF
OUR CALENDAR OF OUR CALENDAR,
WHICH ARE ITEMS 115 THROUGH 143
AND 144 THROUGH 179. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO PULL AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDARS? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ALL
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY BILL 1817, 1832
1907, 2020, 2074, 2086, 2098 21,
OH EIGHT, 21, 31, 21, 65, 21,
96, 22, 79, 23, TEN, 24, 55, 24,
58, 25, OH NINE, 25, 34, 25, 89,
27, OH THREE, 28, 34, 29, OH
THREE, 29, 36, 29, 99, 30, 23,
30, 30, 32, 29, 32, 54, 32, 55.
SENATE BILL 536 632 393 551 1447
379 504, 571, 899, 910, NINE,
26, NINE, 58, 997, TEN, 19,
1069, 1090, 1150, 1166, 1180,
1187, 1197, 1213, 1244, 1246,
1371, 1391, 14 1114, 12 1415,
1443, 1453, 1455, 1465, 1471,
1527. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE FIRST ITEM. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD I
DURAZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER. I SMALLWOOD,
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I
WAHAB, I WIENER I WILK I. AYES
40 NOES ZERO. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED. NOW IT'S
TIME FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS? VICE
CHAIR. SENATOR EGGMAN, JUST AS A
MEMBER, I UNDERSTAND THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
THE CLOSE OF SESSION IN ROOM
1200. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS NEEDING TO MAKE A
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT?
YES, SIR. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS WEEK. THIS WEEK WE STARTED
WITH 570 ASSEMBLY BILLS. LET'S
TALK ABOUT TOMORROW. TOMORROW?
OUR ENTIRE UNIVERSE OF ASSEMBLY
BILLS WILL BE BETWEEN 30 AND 40.
30 AND 40 ASSEMBLY BILLS. I WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE AMAZING WORK OF EACH
AND EVERY MEMBER ON THIS FLOOR.
YOU HAVE BEEN SUPERB. OUR TOTAL
UNIVERSE TOMORROW FOR SENATE
BILLS ON THIS FLOOR WILL BE
APPROXIMATELY 50 TO 60. SO
TOMORROW I'M GOING TO ASK FOR
SOME PATIENCE. THERE ARE
SPECIFIC TIMESTAMP BILLS PER THE
72 HOUR RULE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO WAIT AROUND FOR, SO
PLEASE DON'T TAKE ANY OFFENSE,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ONE UP.
MAY TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
BREAK. TAKE ONE UP, TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF BREAK. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GO SLOW STEADY. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE JOB DONE
FOR CALIFORNIA TOMORROW WE'RE
GOING TO START TOMORROW AT 1
P.M. 1 P.M. SO LUNCH WILL BE
AVAILABLE AT NOON. LUNCH
AVAILABLE AT NOON IN THE MØT
LOUNGE. THEN WE'RE GOING TO DO 1
P.M. AND I HAVE A I'VE HEARD A
RUMOR BUNDT CAKES ARE COMING IN
AT 230. SO THAT'S RIGHT. THERE
WILL BE DOORSTOPS. SO LUNCH
AVAILABLE AT NOON. WE START
SESSION AT ONE. YOU HAVE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB THIS WEEK. THE
DESK STAFF HAS DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB OF PRESIDING OFFICERS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR SATURDAY,
AUGUST 31ST AT 1 P.M. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. BEFORE I WANT TO
MAKE A CORRECTION, FOLKS, SENATE
ENERGY WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM
1200. IN THE SWING SPACE. OH,
THEY SAID SOMEBODY SAID. IN THE
NEXT 15 MINUTES, THE SENATE IS
ADJOURNED. WE'LL RECONVENE
SATURDAY, AUGUST 31ST AT 1 P.M.